This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Christina
is lifted produced by somatics.
Yeah,
I just threw that in there. I just want
to let you know what they did was that um,
really big things coming up.
I have a huge,
huge thing coming on her huge
Boehner coming next month or so. Um,
I can't even get into the, uh, look, it's
the biggest thing I've ever done. Yeah.
Yeah. But you have to go to my tour
page, sign up for the mailing list,
cause I won't be announcing it.
Only be doing it via mail at first and
then later on you can hear about it,
but there'll be a special thing and just
letting you know there's a prompt when
you go to the tour page and
you put in your email address,
just letting you know a gene that added
show at brass balls beach is almost
gone. So if you didn't get a chance
to get tickets to Friday, Saturday,
I'm doing one Sunday,
August 26 and breast balls,
beach at the Improv there be
a second show in Montclair.
The one I added on Wednesday,
November 14th is more than half gone,
so it's not going to be around much
longer is the third show in Philadelphia
that was added is also coming
up at about half capacity.
And that is November.
Uh,
I believe the 17th uh,
yeah,
17 so you want to get them now, Tom
segura.com/tour. There's a couple others,
cities, um, that still have some
tickets left a fart go. No, not Farco.
But um,
Fresno,
Fresno has some tickets left Bakersfield.
Very few tickets left in a second show
in Eugene and I think boys the seed,
Idaho Ball Sacramento
or they're all at toms.
[inaudible] dot com slash
tour Jean [inaudible]
Jean. Um, November 24th I'm in man, Diego,
California at the House of Bruise
and then a December 7th in filler up.
Delphia come see me there.
And then the eighth I am,
I added a 10 30 show in June.
Dork titties at the grammar she theater
first show is, it's sold out. So
get your tickets if you live in a,
in any of those places. There you go.
Christina p online.
There you go.
Jean unline gene,
there's a lot of fun stuff to cover.
We have so many things, a great
guests coming as well. Oh Jeez. Oh,
and gene's going to be a lot of fun.
Did you see what I did there?
I don't know if you noticed,
but I'm wearing the exact same jacket
that's in this promo picture. Oh yeah.
Could have been wearing the
same shirt almost. Um, okay.
You ready to do it? I am.
Let's party. Here we go. Make sure.
Yep. We're all set. Here we go. He,
he,
oh, oh, oh.
Bear walks into a restaurant
and says I liked the grill.
Uh,
grilled cheese tendered.
Says what's with the big
okay.
Oh,
don't bring anyone loving. Well, welcome.
Go to your mom's house.
A man.
Okay.
This made me laugh. Brought back a lot
of memories actually. And Your Dad. Yeah,
of course. Do you feel like you'll never
know that type of joy? I've thought,
why can't I be like this?
I wish I knew this.
This feeling. Yeah, like just
laughing and stuff. It's so not funny.
I mean it's just, it's super joy. So joy.
Okay. Yeah. Yeah. It's like
multiple,
multiple choice questions.
You sound,
are you okay? All right, so funny. I
can't believe I'm blanking on the front.
The best part about that,
by the way,
that's either that is my dad laughing
at his own thought, like his own joke,
right? He goes to answers multiple choice.
This guy is reading a joke book, right?
Like a de a Corny, yeah. He's like,
there's an ultimate dad Boehner.
Don't you wish the bar was super low
on humor for us like that can we just
laughed a little. I wish I could walk on
stage and just fucking do this. I know.
Look at this guy.
All right.
Bear walks into a restaurant and says,
I like
came and get through the arts
into your restaurant and says,
I like the grill
grilled cheese or tender
to says what's with the big
okay. I can't even say
it. Got It. What if,
what if he's a real pos in real life
and he beats the shit out of this way.
Like how much you like that? I know.
It makes you laugh. You sick. Fuck
me. That means you, you're
so fucked in your head.
Was that thing I was telling
you about? Uh, no I don't.
Nope.
In the green room and Bray
a couple of weeks ago,
Josh potters with me and one
of the servers came in and she,
we were,
the TV was on,
I think tiger was playing and started
talking about like member his, how,
how fucking on top of the world he was.
Then we started talking about how
Tiger Tiger fucking dumb name is tiger.
I know that a few times, but you
hear it and you're like, okay,
well that's Brendan Schaub son's
name is tiger. Yeah, it is.
Yes it is.
Sorry Brennan.
Okay.
And, and in this case it's a nickname in
Brendan's. It's his real name. Great Name.
Did I say so?
Uh,
so when tiger was on top of the world,
it's like just how on top of
it he was. Yeah. And then he,
he had all these hoes on the
side like so many hoes. Right.
And we were just talking
about, you know, imagine,
well just like how backed up he was,
what it was,
we're pressing to act out in the way
he was acting out and we can't wait to
throat fucking ass. Weird. Pretty crazy
stuff cause he was a pretty buttoned up.
He is a pretty buttoned up guy. Well
yeah I mean golf in general like that,
that image is real straight laced.
I'm going to throw fuck the shit
out of this horror right now. No,
I mean John Daly was the only
guy who was openly like that.
But I mean he also had like some real
problems and he also was never nearly as
good as tiger is. Like the best
thing we've ever seen. Just dominant.
Started it like two years old
and he was dominant though.
I mean just kicking people's ass every
week in this thing. A lot love, big time.
Big Time Golfers. They'll have, you know,
a few big wins in their career where
they're competing every week. But like,
you know, having like all these
majors like week after week,
just crushing people.
Anyway,
we're talking about this about imagine
them being one of those girls and you
know he's throwing you cash on the
side and some of them are cool with the
arrangements.
Some of them probably like a lot of
times with these things start to get like
how come I'm not like the main girl,
you know?
And he had too many going on to it yet.
No one wants to be second or third place,
not real. And he's just like don't
fucking make eye contact if you see me
in the hotel because he had those
like arrangements like I know,
you know he would arrange the hotel
through one of his buddies or you know his
handlers. But also it was like,
you know, make sure no one,
you don't me in the lobby.
Okay. Cause he's tiger.
So he gets to maintain
all this make sense.
If you're the Ho like that's your
job is to be, if you're a good whoa,
you're supposed to be like of course.
But what happened was,
I think he started to get, some
of them were like, wow, you know,
they're also around somebody who's
so like so famous and so rich.
I think they started, some of them
started to get like, I want one more.
Where's my stuff? Yeah, I want some
stuff. I want some stuff too. Anyway,
then we started talking about,
uh,
other well known people and
I'm like, this is like, oh,
Jay. Not even like, I know.
I imagine Oj, you know, approaching,
you now be like, hey, how you
doing sweetie? And you're like, Hi,
if I'm 20 years old and don't,
and 1994 never happened. Yeah.
I was born in [inaudible] 96
or 2000,
but what was the other girl? Casey.
Casey Anderson. What was her name now?
And I know you're talking about,
but I know she's a real sicko too.
What's her fucking name?
I'm Casey Anderson.
It's Casey, uh, Shit.
I ain't got no bandwidth
for this stuff anymore.
I don't follow these cycles like you do.
I don't have as much interest,
if you will. Casey, Casey,
Anthony, Anthony, Casey, Anthony.
So now she, uh, I just
drinking water guys.
Yeah, that's what I do.
She was found not guilty.
Right? Sure. But a lot
of people, I don't know,
a lot of people
wait was she's dead Casey.
Anthony's dead. No, she's not dead,
right? I don't know. No, no,
no, no. Okay. So anyways,
she was charged and she was,
I think she was found not guilty.
Yeah. It was found like the,
the verdict was greeted with
public outrage. But anyways,
people fucking love,
uh, some people like love this
woman and they really, you know,
like she's, she's cuter
than I guess, you know,
most people you find charged with crimes,
like she doesn't look like I'm Eileen,
Eileen Warner who's craziest shit
like a man. And she's like, yeah,
she's a cutie. So imagine,
let's see if, uh, if there's,
is there 2018 images of her now?
Oh boy doesn't,
well, she's not in prison. Oh, she's
hot. Looks good. She looks great. Um,
but imagine we're like, like this one
right here. Yeah. This picture of her,
you meet her, you go out
on a date with her, right.
Maybe you meet her at the vet's office.
See,
she's carrying her dog groomer here
and you're like, oh, I got a dog too.
And you go out with Casey, you go
out on a date. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Great time on your date.
And then you have drinks afterwards
and you're back at her place.
Yeah. You start making out.
Things start to go further.
And then she unbuckles your pants.
She goes down on you and she
starts giving you the blow job,
a blow job. I mean, she's
spitting on your balls, right?
She's gagging on, you're Dong,
she's licking under your balls,
like Kinda toying with your
asshole. And you're like, wow.
And then like every time you're like, ah,
that's really spits back. I don't know.
Ah, she's doing all types of her
tricks. You're like, this is crazy.
Expecting it to be like this.
And then as you get,
you're inching towards your
org, you're like, oh my God,
your eyes are rolling back
to the back of your head.
And just as you come,
like you're like,
oh my God. And you start coming. She
goes, I killed my fucking daughter.
And you're like,
ah,
yeah.
Uh,
it kind of ruins your orgasm.
Yeah, that is funny time. You know
how you're laughing right now.
If that is how like the
dad boners laughing.
I know that that's your
version of a lighthearted dad.
Joe Is Casey Anthony confessing to
murdering her kid during a blow job.
God, you're so sexy. Oh,
Jay. Like, oh Jay's bang.
That one makes me laugh. Maybe cause I'm
a mother and I don't want to hear it.
So can we change it to a girlfriend?
Kayla, our wives killing. Oh,
Jay's on top of you. Yeah.
Okay. That, that one's funny.
They can use to pound town.
Then you're like, Jesus, this guy for bad
hips and knees. He can really throw you.
Do I know his history or am I, I guess
you're like, wow, he was not guilty.
If some of your friends are like you're
going on with Oj Jan, you're like,
he's nice,
he's not guilty.
He takes you like a nice restaurant
and then he takes you to like,
he drives past Brentwood and he's like,
I used to live here but to like
does he still have the bronco or is
it a no, no, but he's got like a,
like a different white truck if
smaller. Similar, yeah. Similar.
Similar and he drives you to like a
kind of an east Hollywood apartment.
You're like, ah, okay. Ah,
Brenton was overrated, you know,
and then he takes you up there.
Starts like Tony doing like just kind
of grown like you're kind of young.
He's doing grown man tricks on you.
You know like just advanced moves like
Kinda Rocco stuff. Like maybe he's,
you know what I mean? Like
pension, your test law.
And then he started
hitching my tits of hard.
He's like,
is that,
that's your varsity side short.
Well it is what it comes from like an
older guy like that German guy we play
cause like.com this watch this.
You miss him dry.
That is an older pervert.
Yeah. Like an older person.
You've got to up the ante when you're in
your fifties and sixties right? Yeah. He,
yeah,
he's nipples need to be
go down on you a kills it and
you're just begging for it.
He gets into you, he starts just
railing you and you're like, oh my God.
And as you approach, you're like, oh my
God, it's gonna be the orgasm of my life.
You start, you start orgasmic.
And then he, he leans into
your ear and you're like,
yes baby. Yes. And he's like,
I slipped both of them. Okay.
Yeah.
That's an interesting story.
That's a neat idea.
I try and stuff for
like I, yeah, I mean,
I don't know that this is such a
funny idea that I'm wiping tears away.
I'm not sure it's a tier wiper. Like I
see kind of why I technically, it's funny,
but it's not, it doesn't
get me the way. Well,
this is my version of these guys show,
right?
So you want to finish that guys
joke. Oh yeah. Let's see what the,
the bear says.
The bartender says yes to get clear,
walks into a restaurant and says,
I like a groove cheese.
What's with the big pause?
The bar tender ask.
That's the joke. Joke. My parent
doesn't even have a double
closing. Did you get that?
I get the grilled cheese.
I've heard it,
yeah.
Oh, you know what? Maybe he
didn't tell the joke. Right.
I would like a grilled cheese.
What's with the big pause?
I'm a bear paws. P A u. S e p. Aws.
Is that a joke? Because I'm like, wait,
that's not even a dry. So he said,
I'll uh,
I'll have a grilled cheese.
Right. But he didn't tell
the joke properly. Right.
That's exactly what my dad would do.
Exactly right.
You would miss the point of the
joke. The whole timing of it. Yeah.
Yeah.
What joy number when we called my
dad and we'd go outside though.
Oh my God,
I love it.
I love those jokes. Oh, I
got a whole bunch. Okay,
so how can you tell a blonde
has been using your computer?
I don't know.
There's whiteout all over the Monitor.
I got one for you too. Okay,
go, go ahead. Go ahead. Okay.
This lot is sitting at a bar
in Chicago watching the, yeah,
the one of these bars where they had
the TV behind the bar and some guy up on
the ledge and getting ready to jump.
So this,
this guy sat next to her and he
says to her, it's too wordy already.
This is the six o'clock
news. And uh, he says, uh,
I bet you he jumps and the bond says,
I bet you your drink.
He doesn't. And all of a sudden, okay,
the guy jumps. And so the,
the guys at the blind is,
I guess you owe your $20. And he said, no,
that was for a drink and we can't take
the money cause I saw it on the five
o'clock news and the blinds this.
So did I.
But I thought he might change his mind.
I think that's hilarious.
Let's see. It was, it's so poorly
told. Well there's, it's too wordy.
The setup was too convoluted. It's, I was
like, and this is the six o'clock news,
like, no, it'd be like,
okay, a blonde and an guy.
We're sitting at the bar watching
the six o'clock news. Yeah. The door.
You can I say about the time
and then have the punch be like,
I saw the slide earlier
time. Right. You know,
there's a lot of ways to tell that
joke efficiently. Yeah. He did not. Um,
you know what's funny about
your father is that he, um,
he's kind of an old school kind of dude
and he loves to point out that I'm a
woman constantly. Oh yeah. Like I'm
not really sure know, Christina,
we were watching your special on Netflix
and I think what people like the most
is that you're a woman telling
me jokes and these things like,
yeah.
Yeah.
So any loves to make fun of
me being blonde in California.
[inaudible] loves it.
Loves it. Yeah. I mean, this shit is just
my God.
See, I think Nice Casey has any Oj
stuff's way funnier. Right? Try It,
try it on a crowd to see
if they think it's funnier.
I think we'll get feedback just from this.
I a million a million cycles are going
to write in and say how wrong I am and
how brilliant that is. I know,
I know. How wrong you. Oh yeah.
They always side with the psychopath.
Tom. Christina has just the squared.
Tom's Tom's right.
That's
your whole psycho squad of,
of people. Yeah. You know,
these are the same derelict to buy the
shirts that I don't think are great.
Do you wanna know something amazing? This
is, this is how good God is. God is good
all the time. I'm too
blessed to be straight. How,
how good is God right now? This was
completely unplanned. She had no idea.
None. I didn't tell her, but I didn't prep
you on this. No, you just bring that up.
Added to the store. Oh, less than an
hour ago. Oh, what is it this time?
The piss on me featuring my face,
your mouth open and some
tears. Um, Geez, this Tom,
this is a presale right now.
This is the image that was on my
Instagram that did so well. Um,
that we, uh, everyone was like, puts
us on a shirt. I was like, okay,
so great. Yeah, this was a,
I wonder how many people are going
to want piss on me and beat me.
It was like beard at guy's mouth open
on their chests, but you know, uh,
a judge that kind of a thing.
X h h creative x as a 22 year
old artists who made this.
Um, by the way, I also,
it's not for sale yet,
but I also send the
design to our sock guy,
so hopefully there'll be some piss on me.
Beat me socks.
It's exciting.
When's the FTT Rit?
Well this is all you're
throwing all that at first.
Good tongue replaces that Dick.
Somebody feel like they
crack the code here. Hey,
I crack the FCT RTD code high Hitler.
I became fascinated with the puzzle
presented to the y community.
I think I have solved it.
Um, I took to the streets.
We can walk around pronouncing FTD Archie
phonetically making eye contact with
each person. I pass in hopes
of assistance for inspiration.
I got some dirty looks from some
zooms herbs with blue hair. You're,
they thought it wasn't up to the task,
but I did not let just disheartened meat.
By the time I got home,
I remembered my past relationship with
a Jewish woman and drew from the letter
number association in the Hebrew language.
So I made the chart of the
English alphabet a to Z,
counting from one to
26 signing each letter,
a numerical value FTT RTD added
together is 75 the value of the acronym.
Why am h got me 46 and the P for podcasts
yields 57 seeing that the sum of FTT
RTP was the reverse of the sum.
Why Mhp was all the proof I needed,
that this was indeed a high level
puzzle orchestrated by the main mommies.
Reinvigorated I press on,
I solve for the value is [inaudible] 79
and mommy's 86 knowing that these would
surely come into play, I saw I was all
I needed to solve the riddles. Crazy.
So now with the number, the numerical
values associated with each one,
you have to solve the problem.
Mommies minus FGD RTD equals
1111 is the value of p.
So adding 11 to why match gives you 68.
Subtracting 11 also gets you 68.
Jesus Christ. Now, I have demonstrated
irrefutably that the relationship
between FTT RTD and mommies.
Oh my God,
this is a lot you guys. Yeah. Anyway,
I can't even keep reading
and design added the lexicon.
We shouldn't be lean furniture as FTT RTDs
in the same vein as mommy genes. Okay.
So he's saying we should just,
he found that relationship betweenF ,
g t R tds and the word
mommies. Yeah, you solved it.
It's not an acronym, but a word to
be spoken as its own entity. Gotcha.
I like that. We can call each other
FTT. RTDS is really great for us.
The tongue places that deck,
uh,
this won't be the person for great times.
Rub that Dick Tea Rtd.
Uh,
Bert is definitely FCT RTD.
Want to go for it? Go for it.
Go for it. That guy, too retarded to die.
Uh, for good time. Right to dean,
because that girl to ride the Dick.
Fuck gays and ripe the death.
I don't think so.
Okay.
Wow. People keep and then
look at this amat amazing, uh,
Seagal.
FTT Rtd image created by Evan.
Amazing.
That's great.
What song on his neck
there as this neck fat.
There's just nothing that he's
wearing. One of his Asian, you know,
it's a great portrait.
His eyes and his mouth are so small,
so fat. He's so fat. Uh,
looks good. It's a great image.
Thank you. Haven't, um, yeah,
so, you know, we were
sharing the other day,
whereas a chording stories made me laugh.
Fat guys losing weight too.
Retarded dating.
Would you ever date and are worded person?
I'm sorry,
what?
Would you ever date and are worded person?
No.
Okay. Why not? Or would you, would
you hook up with and are worded,
but what if she's super hot,
babe? Just listen. Hear me out.
What if she's so fucking
hot? He's everything. You
want big, all sloppy titties.
Tiny ways. But donk, donk
gotta be so retarded.
But why?
But why not do I mean,
is it wrong for a normal person to
hook up with an are worded? Yes,
of course they need light. They
like doing it too though. I know,
but you have a, it's like I'll get
up with a drunk person, you know,
it's like you have too many uh,
advantages over them.
Like you don't know that they
can say no, you're just, you're,
you're intellectually superior. You know,
you, you, you can't do that. Okay. I mean,
but what if they're super hot?
Well
really it's about what level of disability
someone has for this type of thing.
Right. Good point. So if
somebody is, I mean let's see,
some like a little bit slower than you.
You could a little slow.
Well that happens all the time. Right?
And marriages, we've seen it. Sure.
I'm going to go where you live
it and then, then there's a,
but then there's something where
it's definitely, yeah, I hear it.
It is a bit like taking advantage of
an innocent yeah. Right. Like a child.
So what about Slingblade are worded is
that guy and go close it wasn't he like
mm, like granting a lot. Yeah. Is he out
of the question for dating? I don't know.
I mean it's a character.
It's a, it's a, it's a,
a non are worded person
playing but he's not fully,
he's not full are worded. No, he's,
so that's a question could, could,
could I, could you date Slingblade
right. That's really for you.
Do you think you could, well I think
remembering back to that movie,
I feel like he's not your type.
He's not my right.
What about Tom Hanks in
um, hey, wait a minute.
Tom Hanks in guilt. What's a movie?
The stupid one with the Jannie.
Oh yeah. Stupid is as stupid
does dude. She hooks up with him.
They even have a kid together. Spoiler
alert. And how has that ethical,
she hooks up with Forrest Forrest Gump.
That's the name of the movie. Hello
back on my mother and father's
play into my life. No, no, no.
She had the mundane bill for me.
Come over to the audience
that around after and he had
her looking at the ground,
I dunno know no floor after what
ahead of me. A hole dug out,
lay down and oh
no, he's a problem. I think he's
pretty with it. I just don't,
I don't like where he's from.
Like I don't want to talk about
holes in the ground and stuff.
You don't even know. I don't
think it'd be a good date. I mean,
I don't think you'd have a great date. I
grew up in the San Fernando Valley, like,
I don't know. Could you do it
with him? Yeah, I think he's,
he's at a level of intelligence.
Yeah. I don't think it's unethical.
You don't know.
And I love Billy Bob Thornton.
I think he's definitely sleep with
Forrest Gump. Well that's the thing.
Jenny did rite aid Jenny
and then they had a kid.
Yeah. So you can apparently, and
he make a hit movie about it.
Yeah. You, that's a good point.
I forgot about your box office success
after you do this. Right. It's a win win.
Yeah. So you would sleep with Forrest
Gump though? I don't. I don't.
He's not my type. I like the edge of a
sling blade or guy more than [inaudible].
Which one would you do it with?
Forest or sling blade. I mean,
I think slingers into some
rough shit personally. Yeah.
Without really knowing much about them.
All that wiggling and it was a,
I mean he's, I feel like
he's pretty rough. Yeah.
I don't think it's going to be like,
I think forest is gentle.
It has like anger staff
that he's repressing. You
know it's going to come out.
I mean he'll,
he'll slice your tits off.
I think forest is going
to kiss your navel and he,
he was always so afraid of free.
I don't think. Is it unethical to be
with him? Apparently no. Then they met.
Like I said, they made a hit movie.
Everyone loves the dime the movie. Yeah.
You know, that's a good, good point.
What's her name that you know who's
Janet? You can write pen Robin. Right?
Do you think that he made her sniff
her butt after like in house of cards?
She made him sniff her if forest her
sniff is but be really fucking awesome.
That was in the scene.
That definitely stolen.
That would have been such a better man.
I come over here,
it's like a forest do it.
He's like sniff but doing much.
I ate lots of peas and carrots.
Does it smell like chocolate there
do you think? Huh? Do you think they're
sexy? It probably was just sweet sec.
He didn't do anything.
I remember he would freeze.
He kind of went just lay there
and he loved it. He's an innocent.
Why isn't that unethical though? I think
it is. I think that's not cool if her,
but apparently he, you know he
wanted it though. That's the thing.
He really loved Jenny. Yeah.
She wanted to help him.
She diverge a nice time.
I
mentioned this guy munching on your box
telling you the story as I don't want
to hear the stories as he's going down.
I knew he stops. Too many words
already. Looks up back down.
I don't like the words the talking
and it's so boring. So did you,
have anybody caught you that
was like this? I did actually.
There was a guy I worked with at the
Department of Public Safety at the
University of San Francisco and my work
study job, I worked in the parking booth.
So I handed out like I worked in one
of those boxes for like four years,
handing out parking. And then there
was another job you could have,
which is called the Charlie unit,
where you gave tickets to people.
And I refuse to do that.
Well there is a kid,
it was way too old to be an Undergrad.
He was like 25 and he lived at home with
his parents and he was kind of a sling
blade adjacent, if you
know what I mean. Yeah.
And one time he did ask me out on a date,
what'd you do?
I was so stunned. I didn't, cause I talked
to him a lot. Like he stopped by the,
the parking booth and I talked to him
and I was always amused by him cause he
was super weird and funny,
you know?
And I think he misinterpreted
that as me being interested.
It's a tough thing to adapt to when
people are nice too sometimes. Yeah.
And I get it like with guys, especially
in college, like you're just,
you're hunting for that stuff
when you start just talking
to them, we're like, oh,
this is the one. Yeah, I feel badly.
And then he, uh, he's like, so you know,
if you ever want to go out on a date and
eat dinner. And I was so stunned. I go,
I don't eat. I'm such a day. I know.
I was like, oh, I don't eat. Huh.
And I tried to deflect it. No, I
didn't mean I was trying to be funny.
I think at the time,
I know that was bad.
There was one guy went on a date with,
it was a car salesman.
We were 21 years old, 10
minutes into the day. He goes,
I've slept with over 76 women. We were
20 years old. And I was like, Ooh,
I gotta go. Where's your curious
to how good he must be? No,
I don't think the way you do.
I,
I was more of afraid of like diseases
and stole this peg is going to get down.
Is that right? Well you sleep with like
street stragglers. Excuse me. Oh my God.
You're,
you talk about your past like you find
these women and stragglers like gutter
gutter slots. No, I don't. Gutter slugs.
You one you thought you got aids from
and since she and you're in your act now,
you just, you recall her so fondly all
the time, but was the closest that I,
there's a time that I definitely thought
I had aids the most. You're so dumb.
I mean you had unprotected sex
with a woman in Africa twice.
Okay. Um, yeah,
I think about that. Uh, but we're,
we're what's your worst suitor?
Well, I mean I had one time, uh,
severely disabled person gave me a flower
and asked me to be their boyfriend.
That's nice. Yeah, I didn't
know how to handle it at first.
So I was volunteering at a
school with the kids, you know,
with a disability. And when, when
the, she gave me, she was like,
be my boyfriend. I was like, oh my God. So
I want it to the teacher. And I was like,
I don't know what to do.
And she told me like, just,
just tell you you can't because
you already have a girlfriend. Yes,
that's what I did.
That's sweet. That's not,
that doesn't really count.
No, no, no. Well, no,
but I mean like what about nasty bitches?
You've had like a nasty bitch.
The okay man, this one, this is fucked up.
I feel bad about this one kind of.
So I was at a bar on sunset and this is
like in my early thin days here in La
and I was just, I did it. I
wasn't really a bar proper,
but I happen to be out with a friend
and we're at the bar and a woman just
approached me and it, here's the
thing about bars, this is no joke.
You know they are dark bars at night,
have favorable lighting and beer
goggles, help tale. But I wasn't,
I wasn't, I mean I have maybe a beer
or two. I wasn't fucked up. Yeah.
And she just approached
me and she was like,
hey blah blah blah and like very
forward. And I was like, okay.
She asks me for my
number. I was like, yeah,
all right.
I gave her my number,
had a small brief conversation and then
I split and she called like either that
night or the next day pretty quickly
to set up going out Friday or Saturday.
And I was like, okay, cool. And I
went and I picked her up. Oh Man.
Oh Man. It was so bad.
What I was seeing was so,
so bad. I was, I it to just be
like, I got, I, I have a hernia.
I just, I mean who I saw, I had
zero recollection of her. Yeah.
Really the lighting lighting and yeah,
she was just nasty.
It was, she was, yeah. It was
fucking upsetting. Wow. That's,
but I mean, I was nice about
it, but I was like, mm,
no. You know, what did you do? Uh, we
went to like, somebody was having to wait.
She knew was having a party somewhere. I
just, you know, the whole time I was like,
I got to get out of this.
I was trying to be like nice about it.
And then I remember
there was music playing.
You don't actually remember is that the
party that she took me to had somebody
deejaying and sister Nancy BombBomb.
That's our song that you
and I, but I didn't know the
name of that song yet. Yeah.
And I remember that at
that party she took me to,
I went up to the DJ cause I
had heard the song before I go,
what's the name of this song?
And he told me and then that song we
came something you and I bonded out early
in our relationship because that's
your phone. Then we went back to her.
No you did. No, no, no. I had to
drive her back and she was like,
do you want to come in? And
I was like, no. She's like,
do you want to just like park here? And I
was like, no, do you want to? I was like,
no, none of it. That's so
horrible. But that was,
I wasn't a dick about it, but
I remember being, I mean, what,
what was the thing to do there?
Should I have just like at the beginning
saw her been like, oh shit. Okay.
No, I mean here's, here's
where the kids today have it,
right with this app dating is that they,
they don't commit to dinner.
They don't commit to a lengthy thing.
They commit to like coffee. Yeah.
So if you don't like that person, you
got a quick out like, oh, I got diarrhea,
I got to go. Yeah. And
that, that's a mistake.
I think that we could've preempted
that whole thing of making the date
potentially shorter. Yeah.
That's basically what they
do today. Evening from me.
Yeah. It sucks. It nothing's worse
than a bad date to and you're like,
and then my fear to offend, I just stuck
it out. Yeah. I didn't want to be like,
I don't find you attractive.
Well, here's the thing,
because if you think of
it in a humane fashion,
like you can be kind and maybe get to
know somebody and just spend the night.
And I was trying to be humane, but I
think she was like, well, we're on a date.
And I'm like in the U
I n n e bitch. No, but that's true. If it,
if she can't sense that you're not vibing
on her sexually. It's kind of, yeah.
Didn't I tell you a couple of an ass?
I told you about one girl who,
who was oh yeah,
this was a funny one to me where we were
in college and it was like junior year.
Um, and the end of the year
was approaching. Oh yeah. I,
I was hanging out with her and we were
in my dorm room and we were making out a
little bit on my bed and then I just
remember getting like a shove and she's
like, you're snoring. So I fell asleep
on her, not on her, but you know,
next to her. And I was like, what? She's
like, you're snoring. And I was like,
I mean it's late.
I think she didn't marry yet.
That's the whole lifetime of that shit.
And she left and then she was going
home for the summer and she was like,
well, I was staying at school. So she
was like, it's like four hours apart.
And she goes, well, you know,
here's my number or whatever, let's,
because we went out a couple times,
you know,
let's stay in touch the
summer and you know, maybe see
each other. And I was like,
yeah, cool. And then I just never
texted her or called her or anything.
And then in the fall she rolled around,
she was like, you're an ass like day one.
And I was like, why you didn't
text call once? And I was like,
I mean,
see, I would've played it cool. I
would have ignored you and been like,
whatever dude is a fucking asshole. Like
tell him with my whole thing was like,
I just felt nothing for
the guy doesn't call,
he's not interested and
she wasn't unattractive. I
was like, I just, you know,
it's not, it's not your jam.
Hostile. Angry Hungarian. Yeah,
the gigantic or we need to
Franklin tits. Yeah, exactly.
You're waiting for your genes.
That's right. So it's a combination.
I just was like, whatever.
And then I dunno,
we went out like once or twice more.
Oh, you did go out with her again?
Yeah, but I mean, I mean, you know,
it was like I got guilted into it kinda
sounds like there wasn't even guilted
into it. I was just,
that's a dick move cars.
Then girls think that you're
interested if you're like, ah,
there's no one else in south
care. Totally. We'd stayed. Yeah.
Friendly. It wasn't like bad with
her. It wasn't bad. It was fine.
There was one guy I dated in
college who was super cute,
but there was too much of a
language barrier, language barrier.
He was a Spanish exchange students.
I love them.
You know me come on
Puerto Rican Spaniards.
I married if I can say Gouda.
Um,
and he was so sweet and so
just kind to me and wonderful,
but he didn't speak enough.
You're a fucking Jody. So chasers.
So I kinda,
I kinda perse we couldn't go.
I just felt like I can't talk to
this person. How weird is that?
I can't just hide the, I'm not
a dirty slot. Like you are,
you just hook up with every old
strap. This guy from Spain, Barcelona,
he spoke so little you couldn't
even, yeah, it was tough.
Like he was his first year here. We
went on a date and I, I liked him.
Like I said, his energy was great. He
was sweet, super sweet. But it was,
there was such a barrier culturally too,
like, you know what I mean? We're eh,
yeah.
He was sweet.
That's what you would've done to me. No,
he was sweet guy. He's, he stalls. We,
we still, uh, every now and then on
Facebook. Oh Jesus. Really? But through,
through other college friends in
a group of friends. Yeah. Yeah,
me too. I have a couple of girls who
I thought were so smug and Hans Suite,
but their language science day,
smoking hot day. It was cute,
but he wasn't smoking hot.
You're much your, I still,
you know, check in on it when you die.
It's a college friend.
He became a circle of French for sure.
Is He married now? No, I don't. I
don't even know. I have to ask him.
I'll have to ask him.
Are you married one Jose?
I tried to think of other bad dates.
I mean I feel like they're all bad.
Dates are just terrible.
That's probably why I wasn't a big dater.
I felt I just not good at it.
I don't like it.
I have to know the person
and then we then you'd go for
why don't you do it to me?
Huh?
Hey,
thank you.
Earn that one.
You earn that one with your one
Jose emails that nobody knew about.
Nobody knew. You can log into my
Facebook any day and see the big extreme.
Yeah, I had my headphones
off. I can only hear.
Oh Geez. That was good.
That was good fun. Um,
we have a great guests coming up in a
little bit here. And why do you hate me?
Cause it was so nasty.
But you know we have to talk about,
because we were watching some show,
we were watching below deck and
I'm not gonna put my headphones on.
I took it off.
I know I'm playing other clips.
Nellie's what other BARF clips line?
No,
I don't think I was born yesterday. So
I don't know your tricks. I promise.
I promise. Nope. We're watching
below deck. Put them back on. Nope.
Cause I don't trust you. I'm not
going to play anymore. That dirty. No.
Will you need to put them on dirty Latin
trickster. I'm not going to do a bar.
We swear on our children's eyes.
I want you to say,
I swear in our children's eyes. I swear,
I swear I wouldn't say that. I swear.
Children, plural. Mother of two of your
children. I just want to, I swear to God,
if I hear a fucking Barb said, no,
I'm not playing it. I'm not. I'm not.
We're watching below deck.
Slowly putting him on.
We're watching deck and there's girls,
like,
one of my favorite things you
do is this dumb girls lace.
Well,
there's a face on your stars.
There's a few favorite things
you do. Oh my God. Oh my God.
Oh my God.
Seriously.
We have to go get her son soon,
but before we do, oh my God,
you guys are so disgusting. Yeah. I
Til I got to put my kids to the, uh,
there's a super flirt guy
who's flirting with all these.
He's flirting with every girl on there
trying to hook up with the garage. And uh,
one of the girls,
like out of the,
you're the right guy for bed.
And he's like,
why not just that?
Because I lot of bit tried to apply hot
pepper sauce the way by a dotted tries.
My mom loves her. I, he
waits, I, his spoils her.
That's what I would look at,
far
a Todd bits about it.
Just like daddy about pretzels.
That's the worst thing you can do is, is
girl, it'd be like, you are a princess.
That is the worst.
You're so special that somebody should
treat you exactly the way I treat your
mother.
Right.
But people forget that your mother
most likely bore a few of his children.
Yeah. Probably raise those babies.
Took care of the husband for a year.
You guys have been together.
We've been through ups and
downs and licked his bean bag.
Dark does cock for years.
And
what did that
when things weren't great.
Yeah. And like, yeah, yeah,
maybe given him a sympathy handy,
you know, three weeks postpartum,
still stitches, healing,
milky tits underneath,
pull down,
maybe throws her husband and bone cause
she knows it's been a long time since
they've, right. So you go like,
hello, this is a, that, that's why,
that's why she gets, that's why your
mom is treated so special by your dad.
He's like over time. Yeah. The
love grew into a special thing,
right? It's all you should initiate
dating that way. Well, it's first of all,
there's nothing,
there's nothing less attractive than the
girl who leads with the prince ass car.
It's so gross. I went out with a girl one
time out of here, out upon signing up.
This is like, I would have
died. A guy misses lay. I smell.
This is the sound of my voice and
Mrs, uh, like the touch of my head,
I thought that's one of the last ships
or bay like told me that a few times.
Yeah, it's attractive. Right? Can I, can
I tell you the problem with women best,
the way I smell this is all about
guys, this is wrong. This is wrong.
The reason women think this way is
because of soap operas and romantic movies
with, uh, you know, what's his name?
Ryan Gosling and all this horse shit.
They fill our minds full of nonsense.
It most guys aren't going
to do that for ya know,
and the guys that will are full of
shit. All right. That's the problem.
They're a fucking total FTT.
Our tds total shit run for the hills.
If he's goring thumb rings and fucking,
you know, sensitive guy, forget it.
Um, that's true with
the princess girl, man.
You're doing your daughter's a disservice.
I told her just be your
own person and yeah,
try to find someone that she likes him.
He an equal. Yeah. Yeah, I agree. Yeah.
You didn't want to be relationships
that are on pedestals. Right.
Cause then she's implying the power
balance should be that I'm on top. Yeah.
And this guy of worships me. Yeah.
It's so weird. It's very weird.
There's also Mike Tyson coming jokes.
We're jumping in.
I did not tell him Mike
Tyson one. Okay. Yeah,
I did tell an Oj I was
telling her earlier, well boy,
imagine if you went out
with Oj on a date now,
but you didn't necessarily know
everything. No. You do. You kind of know,
but you're kind of not.
Yeah. You kind of like a,
you're willing to go out on a date with
them. Yeah. And then he takes you out.
You have a good time. Yeah. And then
you started poking out. Good time.
You start hooking up and as you orgasm
is like the orgasm of your life.
Yeah. He leans in and whispers in your
ear like, I cut those motherfuckers next.
Yeah.
And then that just makes you come
harder. Yeah. You're cute. You're like,
wow, now can I only be, can I only
listen or watch true crime? To have a,
like a, a massive orgasm sets you
up for a fetish, I guess. Yeah.
It looks like you two are Kendra
jokes spirit. I had no idea of. Right.
Do you like murder shows too? Uh, I just
got into evil genius. Oh, it's great.
Okay, so you're into that one. It's
great. Yes, I'm good. I'm excited.
I think it's like I,
I like murder shows and I,
he like gangster shows.
I think for the same reason because I
secretly want to be a gangster and a
murderer. Oh there you go.
Where it's like, but I'll
never do it cause it's like,
you know wrong. It's an escape.
Yeah. Who are you ordering first?
Let's talk about it. I mean I think
you've got to go family members. Oh,
certain family members.
Interesting choice. I agree.
Now I'm on board with family.
Yeah, like extended family.
But like just those extended family
that whenever their name pops up on your
phone you're like, oh, I'm
about to be miserable. Yeah.
That's all really good.
Like that's my whole goal in life is to
be the person that when my name pops up
on your phone you don't
go, fuck yes, that's it.
That because we all have those people in
our lives where that person never calls
you and goes, hey, just wanted to say,
I just saw your work and congratulations
and the life and oh my life.
It's going well, everything's fine.
Like you just have some people in your,
in your world where that is never
the appearance. It's like, all right,
this phone call is going to cost me
a couple thousand dollars, you know,
and it cost me a few days
off my life probably. Yeah.
Just because of the stress
and all that and you know,
and it's never just a simple
fix. It's never just like, Hey,
uh, I know you have AAA. I don't have
AAA call AAA and get triple. It's,
it's more like, Hey, I'm at
a Pr, I'm going to prison
in Morocco and like,
you can't afford to go to Morocco.
I got here long story, uh,
it, you know, it's like,
can you go to the State Department
and it's like this huge thing do,
are you good at the blowing off? Yes. Yes.
So he didn't get to learn it
though. You're like, you get better.
I'm blowing off family or anyone,
everyone.
I'm teaching my wife
right now because there's,
because she's such an
accommodating Combinator and,
and she's such a loving giving
person. Yes. Yes. She's a good person.
She's wants to make everybody happy.
She brought cookies over four cookies
for you in a hole and homemade juice.
Yeah. Come on. Homemade juice.
So yeah, apple, ginger, we're
going to clean out your,
Colin's great, uh, well
that, that on the show. Yeah.
So like she's a good person who,
whenever crazy family or friends calls up,
she's like trying to be very,
she's trying to be very helpful.
It's going to solve the problems.
And I just,
I finally to like sit her
down and be like, no, you can,
you can just not do that. She's
like, yeah, but then they'll,
then they'll not like me. I'm
like, they already don't like you.
They're already just calling you up to
use you for because they know that you're
the helpful one.
So just don't be the helpful one that
that's why I'm so envious of some of the
members of my family that
are just complete fuckups
cause it's like no one would
ever call them. No one would ever
call him and be like, Hey, uh,
you've been in jail three times in,
in and out of various rehabs
and you may have killed someone.
Could you help me move?
Leggy let, let, let,
like no one would ever say that your
family, cause Tom and I, we compare crazy.
I've got a lot of alcoholism, mental
illness. We checked those boxes.
I think like, I think like we're playing
like dysfunctional family. Bingo.
Alcoholism. Yes. Mental illness. Yes.
Hoarding. We got, yeah,
we got one hoarder. Uh, I think Tom,
how does it go if there's pathways?
Oh yeah. Yeah. So level one is like,
I like a lot of shit
too.
Um, is like, uh, basically, um, clutter,
a lot of clutter. Trash. Yeah. Nothing
is rash starts at three. Okay. So then
it's just trash. If it's like Vcs,
Florida ceiling, but there is a
pathway if they leave a place to walk,
I think that's a four. But it's still
like this person is in deep, deep. Right.
But if you need a shovel to get from one
room to another or if like five is like,
there's like, yeah, there's rats
here, but you know, they're nice.
That's level five where they, where
they shit they shit and they're like,
there's no plumbing here but, right. But
they also don't see a problem with it.
Like someone will be like, did you just
shit like an open bag? And they're like,
where do you feel like they don't even see
live is in the toilet
that no longer works.
And it just piles and piles of selecting
your shit. You're just like, I can't,
I uh, because they don't
have children. They're like,
I created this shit in my body
and I can't get rid of it. Yeah.
There was a few epitopes, map packs and
that's the guy's name. And he called in.
We had him on like years and years
ago and I met him, he's a great guy.
And we were talking about the level fives
and there was a couple episodes where
there's a few times where he was like,
this is not salvageable.
And one of them was so bad that the whole
episode was just to get the person out
of the house. Yeah. The convince him to
leave and then they burned the house down.
They turned it.
Sometimes that's the only solution is
you just come in with a blow torch and a
bulldozer and you guys like,
cause what are you saving?
What slice of them you're saving
important stuff. Like I need that.
I need my nose hair from 1987 and helps
them and all they do is find a new home.
Yeah, I know exactly the same. Yeah.
I like how five they would always,
they would always tie together on
that and also on like 600 pound shit.
They'd be like, they'd be like,
you know, like either like I like,
I just even like his food tastes good.
They're like,
when did you start gaining weight?
They're like, when my dad died and did,
is that when you like start eating
a lot more than they're like,
and then they're like, do you think
it's probably related? And they're like,
I don't know. Yeah. And the same thing
with the hoarders. They'll be like,
my wife left me in 1973 and they're like,
when did you start hoarding 74 and
now nothing will ever leave me again.
I have my house of everything.
Yeah, a lot of trouble. God,
they should just have it because like
all those shows are like on the learning
channel or discovery channel or something.
They should just have a
shot in Freud channel.
That's all the fucked up people in this
world where where we can go and go,
okay, I'm not that bad. Of course.
That's why we watch all the top
age gap, age gap. Love his girl.
I seen that. I haven't seen it.
That's on Netflix but just
the title of it and I'm man,
it's like I'm 60 she's 19 great man.
I'm always curious about
that. You mentioned was that
too right? Was like I'm not,
I don't drink a lot cause like
the whole age gap love thing.
I was once.
The youngest woman I ever dated was 20
years old and I was 29 and I dated her
for like two dates and I ended it when
she didn't know who Johnny Cash was like
literally didn't know.
You know there was a walk the line movie.
I'm not even expecting you to
start. Yeah, like she's like, Ooh,
now I can't.
That's his damn girl.
You guys have a conversation with
their friends.
I just think the threat of the prints
that I don't want to print that. That's,
that's a little pretentious but I feel
like a print that I identify as a print.
That's the same way Bruce Jenner said
as a woman, but he's not really buddy.
I'm a print that.
I just want to find a guy
like weekends or whether you would
sleep before it's got burned out.
We jumped over, we jumped over
it. Whereas we have an intro.
We jumped over.
Our dental
dental update is brought to you by get
quip.com and we are going to ask our
guests, Brad Williams, like a horror
movie and hip hop. That's awesome.
Love that. Brad, do you have
a nice smile? Thank you.
Let me take care of your terrorists who
they're perfect. They're really nice.
Braces. Gotta love it. Do you do
general upkeep pretty well? Yeah.
Uh, yeah, I do general upkeep. And uh,
you happened to go to the dentist every
six months. You really do it. Yeah.
Not everyone does that.
It's weird because your normal is what
you perceive everyone else's normal to be.
And when I find out that people don't
go to the dentist every six months,
I'm like, wrong with you? Like
my mouth is fine. I'm like, oh,
and it's preventative.
Yeah. My friend just, uh,
took his daughter to the
dentist and she had 16 cavities,
16 and I'm like,
what?
How does it like we might be dealing
with a possibly unethical Dennis.
Oh really? They're like,
ah, you have 194 cavities.
This is a joke because it's true.
But I'm gonna tell you the joke though.
So I told the story about
how many years ago out here.
I went to the dentist and I
did go a celebrity dentist.
I was working for the show,
extreme makeover,
and they were giving this deal out for
whitening. So we, a lot of us went there.
And during the general exam,
the dentists' not the celebrity dentist
we had of his trainees. Sure. It goes,
well, you know, let's just do a general
exam. And then he goes, you know,
you have 13 cavities, I have
13 cavities. He's like, yeah,
do you want to get them filled? And
I'm like, well, I don't know man.
This is kind of a lot to take
in right now. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're like, it'll be like $5,600. You
just want to just take it right. I'm like,
what? Just yeah, and I might be a PA,
I don't know man. Yeah. So I was like,
just let me fucking think about it.
And so I go to another
dentist and he's like, uh,
you don't have any cavities. And I'm
like, what do you mean? He's like, dude,
you remember tell you that
was full of Shit. So yeah.
Is this whole thing like I
have a similar story, but yeah,
six months later she was like,
you know what happened the one time I
went to the dentist and there's like you
have 13 cavities. And then I went to
another dentist and he was like, no,
you didn't get it. And I'm like,
that's my story is what happened to me.
I won't tell you what happened to me know.
Cause I had dental insurance for the first
time. I lied. My friend Eric, he will,
he will uh, backup my story. I
want Eric to weigh in on this.
He will weigh in on this.
I went,
cause I had dental insurance and I
went to some scumbag who was like,
you have like, uh, a lot of cavities.
And then I went to my Hungarian
dentist and the valley, there you go.
Who's now retired? He again,
I could waste on boss.
And he said this guy, he's a
fucking liar. You're a scumbag
necrotic guide. You have no
cavities. This is bullshit.
Isn't that it isn't an amazing,
uh,
I once saw a doctor that was supposedly
like a specialist for dwarfs cause we a
little people often have
like respiratory problems.
It just kind of were like
pugs. Yeah. You know, kind of
we can't breathe.
So I knew that I wouldn't see
this doctor and he goes like, he,
and this is back when I was
like 10 and he goes like,
oh you have like severe
like respiratory problems.
Like we need to like prep you for
surgery like in that like in the next two
weeks. Right. Or else you
could die in your sleep any.
And he's saying this to my mom and
my mom's like freaking out and she,
she calls my dad and my dad's like,
oh hold on I gotta friend one second.
We go, we go and we see the
friend who's also an ear,
nose and throat doctor and he just looks
and goes, you're, you're, you're fine.
I don't know what the fuck.
And like we were like prepped for
surgery like the next week and it's like,
what would he have done?
Just cut my throat and look
it and go, Nah, we're good.
Charge him like is that there's people
out there that can do the dental world.
It's much more common. Yeah. But this kind
of shit, that sounds quite terrifying.
Yeah. That's like a whole like,
Brad needs a lung transplant.
We're going to have to do it today.
He's saying things that you can't even
have a, he needs a new frontal lobe.
We that that's the cause
of the dwarfism because
bad frontal lobe. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
So if you just make that the cash,
are you guys ready? Ready to do it?
Let's do it. We're ready. God scumbag.
That's crazy. Um, yeah,
but you have nice teeth and keep them.
So you have raised as any weird
dental things. Yeah. I had said
I didn't lose my baby
teeth for the longest time,
so they had to pull 12 teeth at once or
a lot of little people jokes associated
with it.
I haven't even
lost the, I didn't lose my baby
teeth or as I call them teeth.
Yeah.
So they had to yank all them at once
and they give me a lot of laughing gas.
Yeah.
Remember how old you were or
this was basically between
the ages of Eight and 12?
I had a lot of dentists, Rama. Oh, do you
did have a lot of dental issues. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. And then that is common.
Uh, not for dwarves just for me,
but if you will. But if you look in my
dad's mouth, you're like, yeah, I get it.
Does he have dad enough? He's got like,
oh, like he looks like one of those,
he looks like the part of the
bugs bunny sketch. We're bugs,
throws a grenade into his mouth and like
shuts his mouth and then just real like,
yeah, that's what his mouth looks like.
I'll fuck up. Yeah. Just all fucked up.
But like they're all there, but they're
all at different angles. Wow. You know,
and he's never addressed it now.
Yeah. Yeah. Why would you do that?
I was saying that because
we talk about bad mouth,
like just how like if you think
about your dad, dad's in general.
I'm talking about like Dads,
people our age. You're never like,
oh he's got a really nice
mouth kind of stick. Yeah.
I mean I'll run, I'll see my dad
just be like, Hey, oh you know,
he's visiting and meet you for lunch.
And then I'll just walk up to him,
give him a hug and I'm like, have you
brushed your teeth today? He's like, yeah.
I'm like, it's most terrible. He's like,
really? Are you serious? I was like,
yeah, I go dude, eat a mint. Eat something
too. Yeah. Just to be at least his mouth,
his mouth, dry mouth all the time. Like,
yeah, like what your morning mouth is.
Yeah, it is true. I think. I think they've
just gotten the full, don't give a fuck.
That's true. Full cause you see that
with like clothes. Yeah. You know,
it's like are you, you'd be like, are
you wearing that outfit? He's like, yeah,
why I don't care. No one's touching
his dick. It is about Dick Touches.
Definitely. Yeah. If you're trying
to get someone in touch your Dick,
your standard of fashion high chain,
everything is way higher.
Once you're totally tapped out.
Why would I do anything?
Offer these dictations right
now.
Speaking of Dick touches forest.
Okay.
We're talking about whether or not it's
unethical to sleep with somebody who's
not on your mental level. And we're
like, well, at a certain point,
obviously it's like you would have
well, judgment, intellectual skills,
right. Mentally retarded. Right. Okay.
Cause like all right, because I'm trying
to think of like not Forrest Gump, but,
uh, not Slingblade what was, uh,
what she did a it,
the movie was called the other
sister Juliet Lewis. Yes. Her.
And in that movie, so she was
like, yeah, she was when she was
Juliette Lewis and the other sister
plays like a mentally challenged woman.
Right. But she's not fully,
she's not like life goes on.
Right. And then what's it
called? The other sister. Yeah.
So I, I think if you are in that
spectrum, yeah. Cool, cool. You know?
But once you get to the point where
it's like a w w it's like drool once for
yes, like you know what I mean?
Like once you get to that level,
it's like that. All right. Now what
about, what about Forrest Gump?
Was Jenny ethical or unethical?
I think I,
I think Jenny was fine.
Yeah. Funny Lawn. The level.
But, but he's sweet and sincere
and genuine love for this woman.
Now you could almost say that she was
unethical because he loved her so much.
Not the actual physical part of it,
but because it's like you could take
advantage of him. She did black.
I'm saying though,
is that unethical?
It's like I don't think in that
situation it was, I think like in that,
and that's the thing,
there's a there, there,
there's a spectrum and where are you
on that spectrum and it, like I said,
if it's, if, if, if I don't
even know what that was.
That was from the of the other sister.
Oh,
that was a Giovanni Ribisi who
plays the boyfriend whose movie,
I mean, come on. It's mentally
challenged. People fucking,
and it's a movie.
Is this a,
is that a song? Yeah. Shit.
Oh, that's savage garden.
Yeah. That, yeah,
it goes, yeah. Just like,
yeah.
I mean she's Kinda nice voice. She
seems off. Would you fuck this guy?
I mean that's, yeah. Is that
wrong? Well, he's creepy.
Creepy, creepy thing. Serves
me more than the mental acumen.
The guy just sounds like he'd be like,
Hey, want to get in that van? I got some,
I got some duct tape for you.
Sit down and watch episodes of
2020 together. He's been not,
this guy would not be giving you
neck kisses. No, that's just,
that's like a Lenny of
from of mice and men like,
just think he's going to fuck
the back out of something
floats out.
Now is it politically incorrect for actors
to play mentally challenged or are we
done with that? We'll see. And now, uh,
there was just this article as
we're recording this where someone,
someone got in trouble
today because they're,
they're getting cast to play a gay
person and they're not gay boy. Right.
And I'm thinking like, all
right, big thing with like trans,
you can't put your eyes with the scarlet
Johannson thing. Yeah. She tapped out.
Yeah. It's like, I get that. All right.
When John Wayne was playing gangas con,
that was fucked up.
All right. When he was like,
oh, we're gonna go over there,
I'd get some Hmong goals. Like, yeah.
All right. That's, that's wrong.
When a w was,
was it Mickey Rooney or Andy Rooney?
I think Mickey Rooney Wa wa one of
the Rooney guys. The, uh, he, he,
he played a Chinese person in,
I think it was 16 candles. No,
it was a breakfast at activities. Right.
It was her, that was print that's off.
That was horrific. And he did it
with buck teeth in and the glasses.
Yeah. That was the me. So sorry.
That's where that came from.
Is that packed the cataract
cataract? Oh yes. Yeah,
that's bad. But like, but
back then they were like,
this is one of the best
comedic, but you're like, this
is fantastic. Well, I mean,
yeah. Yeah. Some movies don't hold up.
You know, Dumbo is a prime example.
But like, yeah. Some words.
Yeah. So like, yeah, that is,
that is completely egregious.
But when you have people like it's
called acting, you're, you're,
you're playing someone,
you're not. So now like,
are we only allowed to have
people that are like, oh,
well he's an accountant. While you
can't get a fake accountant, right.
Uni How dare you not use an actual account
and there's real accounts out there
that could use that part. No. It's acting
bullshit. Part of, yeah. To, to me
of like the scarlet Johannson thing,
which what happened,
but I don't know what happened through
Hanson signed on to play this. Um,
I think it's based on a real story. Yeah.
About, so a trans person, right? Yeah.
And so there was this huge
backlash like, hm. Um, you're,
you're using a cisgender woman
to play this transport. Yeah.
There are plenty of trans women out there,
but here's my big beef with this addition.
There's a fucking fly here.
Yeah. Additionally, to the, let's
say, well, why can't, I mean,
it's like Brad saying it's an actor.
So I get why you're saying get
the authentic person to play it.
How about the business side of this
where people buy tickets to see scarlet
Johansson,
guess what?
There is not somebody
currently in the Trans Space.
Right. Who is as big of a draw as Scott
and I know you, the argument can be, well,
a good movies, a good
movie and, and like, yeah,
they just need more
opportunities like this. Okay.
But the people who want to make this
movie, right. Our bedding on, hey,
if we can have a movie
star plays a apart exactly.
Can Recoup this investment. Yeah.
You can have this hot, gorgeous,
big titted beast playing right. This part.
Right. And who I would love to see her
play a trans. Yeah. That'd be
so interesting to some degree.
Even some people were getting mad at the
Rock in that, uh, tower tower movie did.
Yeah. Because it wasn't because he
had one leg, he, he, he, it's like,
and somebody's like, well, you what?
You couldn't find an actor who
actually has one leg. It's like, no,
but not the rock.
The Rock is the most bankable
movie star on the planet right now.
This movie would not have fun debuted
the way it did. And by the way,
if you're a person, and like I'll, I'll
say this from my perspective, okay.
Because yeah, there's been
times when, uh, uh, all right,
the guy who played the dwarf in
the Lord of the Rings, not a dwarf,
all the dwarves in snow white
and the huntsmen not tours.
All right. They got, uh,
you know, uh, they did on the very,
the most recent, uh, Willy Wonka,
the chocolate factory, the one with
Johnny Depp deep. Roy is a dwarf,
but they just clone him a bunch of times.
And rather than using other
dwarf factors, it's like, yeah,
I would have an opportunity
to be mad about that.
But if you told me right now that like
Chris Hemsworth was playing a dwarf,
I'd be like, awesome. Yeah, that's a
great representation for my people.
So like the rock, it's like, yeah,
if I wanted a representation of the people
with prosthetics who wouldn't want to
go for the rock because the,
uh,
because the people who are missing limbs,
the only famous one we know about
you right now is Oscar Pistorius.
He killed his wife or his girlfriend
or whatever the fuck. So that's,
that's what we have that's in our
minds about you. So why not Iraq
and their defense? A lot of, uh, people
who were, um, uh, what are you missing?
Limbs
were super supportive of that movie
because I saw a couple of things and they
were like, oh, it's awesome. And the
Rock's awesome. Like representing us. Yes.
But of course people want to get
mad about everything anyways.
I think now people have this
sort of thing where, and, and,
and I hate it because there are people
that have legit causes to be angry,
to be upset, to be offended. And I think,
but right now there's some sort of weird
group mentality where if you aren't
offended by something, you
feel like you're not included.
You're like, oh my God,
I'm not poor.
I'm not part of the cool kids.
All the cool kids are
getting mad about this thing.
I should be mad about this thing.
Or You're searching for your thing,
whatever that is.
And it's like just or you could have
a coconut smile and shut the fuck up.
It's a group think thing to get onboard
and people aren't really thinking. No,
they just, they just want to be offended
for the sake of being offended. So lame.
Speaking of your, uh, I could advice
them both mega history, your tribe.
Do you know that, uh, Hungary
has abolished gender studies.
Can I mention my tribe is
the most sympathetic to
everybody in the beginning of
the week,
24 hours from the Ministry of human
capacities and the Ministry of Justice to
comment on a proposed amendment,
which declares that no gender study
courses can be launched in the future.
All right. Wow. You know, so some people
sound he'll move forward and there's like,
no, no, thank you. [inaudible] Shit.
You don't want this bullshit. It's
an, an ideology, not a science.
So they're going to do away with
it. All right. You know what?
I will say in defense of my people,
they don't like what they don't like.
They don't want it and get the
fuck out. Jews, Jews, Albanians,
Gypsies.
I love that you led with juice.
That's like we killed him and they,
they reelected a guy who
had a openly antisemitic
blah like, right. He's
like, they're a problem.
A lot of people are hungry or like this
guy, it makes less sense. I mean Jews,
right? I mean, yeah. Yeah.
Like we can't really talk shit in America
with our current situation. But yeah,
I guess what I'm saying, at least the
Hungarians are open about being, you know,
racist and wanting to keep
everything the way they like it. Hey,
you know what though,
I'm a fan and this is the thing that uh,
when someone takes this next statement
out of context, this will end my career.
I'm a fan of someone overtly being a
racist just because then it's like,
oh,
your races suck.
I should avoid you where
your clan robes everywhere.
So I can be like, oh, not talking to you.
The worst is when you talk with someone
and you gel with somebody and you're
friends with someone. They're like,
oh my God, this is a great person.
And then they slip in the
comment where the where they're
like, yeah, I mean, yeah,
it's great that we get to hang out here,
but this place really gone to shit
since I started letting the blacks,
and that's when you go, oh,
did not know that about you.
And now you're shocked. Like,
no, I'm a fan. If you're,
if you're a fucking racist,
be a racist all the time so we
can all just be like, oh, okay,
so be open. Yeah. So don't live in
Hungary. That's the point. Yeah.
Do that. You know? It's
like the people were like,
he won't make me a cake for a gay wedding.
It's like,
is that the only baker and how there,
there's other bakers.
If someone was like, I'm not making a
cake for your midget wedding, I'd be like,
okay,
I don't want to give you money right
now is let me give you money fighting to
give the risk of money.
Let's change the outside.
It's like,
you're never going to stop
bullying going stop racism. Never.
It's like trying to stop the wind.
People are fucking crazy
and dump this world because,
because before we had Mexicans and
blacks, we hated the Irish. Oh,
that's true. And it's like, how
would like the Irish, he's like,
we all hear the Irish at one point where
they're like, ah, fucking my hoolahan.
He's the reason why I'm not
successful in life. So like, we'll,
we'll find a way there.
There's dwarves, no joke.
There's dwarves that hate other dwarves.
What's that all about?
Why do they hate the fuck if I know,
like they're, oh my God. But it's like,
they're like,
what are they saying?
It's just like their type of
dwarfism is like, like fucked up.
Or like they,
they shouldn't receive the benefits
of certain things because they're, uh,
because they're, uh, uh, healthier
dwarf. So it's like, oh, we need, like,
we need, we need funding. We need
attention because we're so fucked up.
He has hypoplasia, uh, he's not
very fucked up, so he get anything,
like it's that kind of shit.
That's nice.
Right? Yeah. So it's like, you're never
going to stop this. I know you can never,
you can't
do you accept that the world is full of
assholes and people that just want to
complain about everything. Actually have
an example of one right here. Okay. Uh,
this,
uh,
well I'll just play a moment for it
for you and then we can talk about it.
All right.
Whichever your chicken.
Okay, wait. So here's the
setup. Okay. I heard rape. It's,
this is a at cafe gratitude.
These are animal rights activists
that are basically all three of them.
Yeah. So they're talking about
the fact that would many paper,
so many paper that their case credit,
artificial insemination
of livestock is rape. No.
Something that cafe gratitude the Vegan
cafe owners are doing on their private
farm in Hawaii. So this is
like the setup here. Okay.
How good is your life that
you have to be like out of it
all?
You know,
we got vets that can't get the
correct mental health care.
We got a written racist things going on.
We've got genocides going on in other
parts of the world and you're like, Eh,
I think all, I think artificially
inseminating cows, that's my hill.
That's what I'm dying on is I want
to find something, man. It's so,
I would love for these protesters to hang
out with someone like the black lives
matter protesters and just compare story.
Anything else or anything else?
Just like, oh, you're here because you
want more funding for cystic fibrosis.
That's nice. You want to know
what they're doing to cows?
They're artificially inseminate.
They're raping them.
How's these psychos?
These three cycles are elitist is off
going. That ain't, that ain't right.
I'll show you a raven, a cow. I,
these three fuckers are,
oh,
I protest.
They have a megaphone and they're
yelling at cafe gratitude about,
uh, they're, they're saying, you
know, uh, any tight, what does it,
rape is not love. You
can't compassionately raped
someone as they say that,
that guy walking the dog.
Yeah. Says Mike Tyson did.
And then, then he said Coby
Bryant did. And then he goes,
uh, to somebody else I think are
maybe the camera guy says, show him,
you know, he says, show him your
chicken. I Dunno, he's saw it,
but here's the whole thing again.
And then it goes on.
Great.
Show me your
chicken is shown here to say,
oh,
and there's a woman that cow suit
tell Matt talking about with this.
But here it continues.
It continues.
She's still on the magazine.
Wonderful. Sarah Silverman
had a few good [inaudible],
some dandies lot of female
comics. Actually plenty of
grey rape jokes out there.
There's some solid ones.
You guys a pretty good one.
Funny.
I mean for just a pedestrian walking by
protest those solids pretty good. Yeah.
And
she says
rate my six foot 200.
How much were ridiculous?
Could this be,
does it go on? You know, and I know
where this calf is. This in Santa Monica,
I think of Venice. Do you know what that
is? It's like blocks from the beach.
It's a nice day. The Sun Shining and
she's doing this. You're like, this guy,
he just got off your bike or something.
We'll go have lunch and then someone's
on a megaphone. I tried to rape me,
go to the beach lady,
hold off here.
Here's why.
Here's one of the people who I blame and
in these situations is the boyfriend or
spouse or whoever of these women who win.
Because if my wife came to me and
said, oh, I'm going to go protest that,
I'd be like, oh, like, cool.
What? Um, what are you protesting?
Did you know if they're
artificially inseminating
cows and that's rape and they,
I mean, I'd be like, yeah, you're not
going outside today. You're, you're, no,
just stay in bed. Let's just Netflix and
chill today. Let's go get some cookies.
I always talk about like if I
started grief dancing or wearing
these behaviors, I'd be like, would
you leave me? And he's like, of course.
So that's crazy. That's literally,
that's literally why that is.
Have a spouse love is aware of
that. They can check you. Yeah.
My wife has checked me many
times. I'm like, you're not
wearing that. That's dumb.
That's a minimum level. Yes.
That's, that's bare minimum.
Not like a belief system where it's like,
yeah,
I'm going to spend a gorgeous day
in Venice protesting the artificial
insemination. You can
cafe. It's a Vegan cafe.
It's crazy.
Right?
Women's sounds like Vince Mcmahon.
Danielle, Josh, Mike. All right.
Joe Hayes cut up Sheoak
I want that to be my,
so
Jeff,
that's another thing too with
these social justice warriors.
It's like she's taking it out a
car. Like, do you know what I mean?
Like you say rape was good.
No. You saying like, Hey,
fucking actual rapes were committed
and you're not mad about those. Yeah.
You're mad about the cow, the fake cow
rape. He's making kind of a dad joke.
Yeah. And it was like, I mean
it's not whatever. It's not great,
but it's not good for like for like
a non comedian who just walked by.
He's like, yeah, that'd be bride
dead. And they still are you?
Everyone's still cooking careers.
Yeah. In the public eye problems there.
I know, I know. It is. Hey Stan, a funny
about what gets take like people who get,
um, you know, career's
taken down now. Yeah.
For like jokes and they're like, no. Coby
Bryan. Yes. Settled a rape charge. Right.
Mike Tyson went to jail
for raping someone. Yeah.
Legitimately and be more like, uh,
yeah, but yeah. Yeah, but they,
they paid their debt to society.
True. But as these, and sorry,
he's going down the road.
Fuck some girl.
His fingers all that's right.
God,
that's the most embarrassing part of that
whole thing. Total list of the throat.
Fucking yeah. It's,
it's weird what you're,
what you're choosing to take down.
Yeah. It's arbitrary and that,
and that's what I mean is that, is
there, is there, there's many legitimate,
horrific things that are happening
in this world that we should shine a
spotlight on and should work to fix.
And then there's this,
I think because there's some stuff
that's just take downable like he is,
he's on sorry thing. It's like that's
it. That's an attainable shaming goal.
Whereas like the Mike Tyson
and the Colby, right? Like,
you're not going to do shit,
lady, you're protest. Why?
Because Colby could still make
a, make a three. There you go.
There's too much money. And somebody was
saying, you know the make you cum guy.
Yeah, I'll make you come. Yeah.
How can I forget? Oh wait, no,
this story and I love that guy.
What
does that,
what's the context of this video where he,
first of all,
he really does a nice job of framing
himself out and he posted these kinds of,
gets a little bit dog refer at least.
Yeah. He could post these guns on sound.
Now that's what these guys like
post a daily video where you,
I'd like to have some pussy,
my face
and then talks about how
good of a lover he is.
And so we found like a barrage
of his videos like this is
to have a woman in my home.
What's he watching? I'm trying to
like, oh, that's Rachel Maddow. Oh No.
They get their salary.
He's mad.
Oops.
They don't care about their partner.
So he's like, um, I'm not like that.
Um, see, this is when I see this,
that's when I'm like, yeah,
minority report had it right.
We should just be sending the van
to his house and be like, yeah,
we're picking you up. I haven't
done anything. You will.
You will. You're going to,
you're going to do some shit.
What? And we're like, yeah,
we're like 99.9% sure you're
going to do something.
It's kind of creepy.
I even went and Beaumont
before I, before I went boom, boom. Yeah,
I doubt it's a boom before.
Is that the tactic to get the ladies?
Absolutely. I just walked up to him again.
I make it
a lot before I'd go really
just peaked around throat.
I have that effect on then a lot of these,
okay.
All the same.
Took his teeth out for this one.
Have yet. There should be somebody
out there wants to her cup crisper.
I wish I could pop me a rich woman
harder or younger or whatever.
Older, younger, whatever. I hope older
because looking at him you're like, yeah,
you don't deserve
to have anybody. He won't always got
a goatee. Now he really wants you.
Can I get a soul patch for the next one?
Somebody wrote in,
I was watching the, Oh,
I'll make you a calm guy.
And I noticed his nose and
how it's crooked as it goes
towards the right side of
his face.
Clearly it's been broken.
I like to think it's been broken from
him talking this way to women in public
and the women or her hot black
guy that fucks and fucks good.
Decided to smack him around.
And this might be why he says
things to his camera now, Nolan.
Yeah, I mean it might be right. Strong
theory. Yeah. Strong theory theory.
Very uh, yeah. That, that, that makes
a lot of sense. This can't work.
I know
there's one or two savages out there or,
or if he does it's like,
it's like, all right, but then at
the same time we say it can't work,
but then there's women that date
serial killers, you know what I mean?
So it's like there's nothing, nothing
can really surprise me anymore. And the,
and yet there's some people that
are single like good people. I know.
That's the amazing part to me is making
his videos and it's always the same
thing over and over and over.
Well we'll find out that he,
that he married one of the my 600
lb life women. That'd be great.
That would be great. I just want a woman
to sit on my face. Challenge accepted.
Let's see if you come
out of this one alive,
why would you make a
video without your teeth?
And that's the crazy because
you know it's smoother.
That's the craziest
thing. It also hasn't, sorry.
It has a sign that you're doing
on purpose. No, I did on accident.
We do it on purpose sometimes.
Yeah.
There's some people that have been in
our lives for like more than a decade.
Who are your house? Christine? And
I'm like, she's good Christine.
Well at least I ate.
At least I stopped myself.
I go but it'd be,
but also good for you for not getting
mad cause I hate those people that like
they,
their name is Brittany but they spell
it with like three teas or something and
then they get mad at you when you're like,
oh bri t t and what you're like, what?
Excuse me
as far as the threat is,
um, three days in a heart
instead of a dot. Before the eye.
Um, prednisone at this folder.
I haven't seen this here,
but it says it's no fucking God.
Yeah.
Cause you've gagged like twice.
We played one earlier.
She got really,
Oh this says racist dog owner.
So here's the deal, man.
My wife and I recently adopted
a Chihuahua puppy. Okay.
I feel like it's very important that
this dog stay connected with its cultural
roots.
Therefore we have been teaching
the dog commands in Spanish.
I'm going to laugh at this. This is
going to be so great. It's a spite,
not really speaking or
knowing any Spanish myself,
friends and family think we
are strange for doing this.
But I strongly believe that not training
about it this way makes you a racist
piece of shit.
Why should you have the right to
whitewash your dog's heritage?
I'd like to hear your opinions on this
since Todd is half Mexican or something
like that and Christine
can weigh in as well,
despite her opinion being tainted
with white privilege. Thanks.
Wow. Love the broadcast. This on me.
Beat me. I need to get fucked a lot,
man. Chris. All right.
Well I have to say this is
genius on this man's part.
I think it's fantastic. Yeah, I
mean, I think you should learn alpha.
Maggie,
if you have a German shepherd,
they have those German shepherds that
you can get there were like trained in
Germany and then they, they only
know commands in German. Amazing.
The Brussels Griffon is from Dallas.
Maybe that's why it's
such a fucking stupid dog,
just because we're speaking it
to it in the language they speak.
What four different languages in
Brussels? Major hub, but I mean,
French is the dominant language.
Clearly Betsy needs
to be hearing more from trying
it. Let's try it tonight. We, eh,
March,
I would love to see,
but to me that I mean that, that person's
obviously being funny. Right? Yeah. Okay.
Okay.
I'm not talking to a dog like this.
That's me talking to it. That so
fun. I lose my God damn mind. I mean,
see that's the thing is like
racism without evil intent.
Hilarious. Hilarious. Yes. Larry,
you mean this dog? We should,
I should teach you a command
to teach your, your Chihuahua.
I've been watching El Chapo,
the series on Alex,
which is not just in Spanish,
but it's all Mexican slang. Um,
so maybe teach your dog,
uh, seeing that the way,
like you said way is like
a, you know, it's like dude
dangled, took a meek
to tangle. [inaudible]
Django. I have to eat something.
Well it's like I have your food.
It's fucking good.
Chingona and then just
you hit the Mallory,
just tell him that that could
be like when to attack someone.
You just see someone
and it's a Chihuahua. So it'd be
hilarious. So you can do it as a joke.
There you go. Cause it's not going
to be like, it's not like if I,
like I have a 70 pound pit bull,
so if I said like attack,
like I could let Jimmy and we like
terrify someone. She's his cries.
Your dog train like that? No, not at
all. He's the sweetest thing ever.
So like you would never do it,
but like now I'm tempted to just like
walk up to people and like Diego Kale,
you know what I mean? Like have someone
like freak the fuck out. Cause you would,
oh my God, I'm, I'm just fasten.
Yeah. He's a massive, massive best.
He's just, I mean, granted it's me,
so he's massive to me. That's right.
Sounds like we see him
and it looks like R. Dot.
What's a saddle doing on him?
I think I got here. Uh, yeah,
my God. Yeah. Uh, we, we
actually got the dog. Uh,
my wife got the dog when I was in
Houston, Texas. Oh, I wasn't even there.
Really? Yeah. How long ago? This is like,
this is like a month and a half ago,
so yeah, it's a new dog. Yeah. I
mean new dog. And his name is Diego.
Diego rescue or a yeah. Yeah, they uh,
they found him chained to a church in
Compton. I'm a dog stuck life. Yeah.
But he's, he's the
sweetest dog and like, uh,
I feel weird telling these stories because
I know bill burr had that bit where
it's like his wife got the dog got also
got a pit bull while he was out and then
he was nervous like coming
home to the dog. Um, but yeah,
so I had to come home to the dog,
like really scared because I'm like,
well I'm walking.
So I had like my wife come out with the
dog on a leash and like meet me outside
the house and then I walk the dog and
then I walked the dog into the house.
So it's like I, I'm, I'm, I'm
a dude, I'm fucking alpha.
And then the dog immediately
got gun in the house,
just turn around and jumped on me and
started like licking my face and I'm like,
love the dog. That's good. Well,
and it has no hostility from doing,
it's the best.
Then like when a midget walks at pit ball,
everyone just goes like that.
That's,
that midget knows something like
that's a bad reality show. Yeah,
I was on it. That's the weirdest part.
Pit boss. Yeah. You were on Pippa?
Yeah, I did a roast of Shorty
Rossi. Oh Wow. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. Wow. What was one of the jokes?
Fuck some something about he
likes pit bulls cause its head.
It looks like a pit bull testicle.
I don't know.
Do you find that with certain cultures
of people react to you differently?
Like I dunno,
the same cultures that are wowed by magic.
I had a joke in my attic
that different races respond to me.
That's what I'm asking. Yeah. Yeah.
And it's true where it is
true, right? Yeah. Oh yeah.
Like give us some insight and,
and all right,
I'm essentially going to do my joke,
but at the same time it's real. So,
uh, white people are very, like,
when their kids stares at me,
it's like he's the kids curious.
The parent is horrified.
Right. It's like, and they're like,
grabbed the kid's head and like turned
violently turn the kids had away and
stuff like that. And that's,
to me, that's, that's a
bummer cause it's like you're,
you're trying to tell the kid like,
this person doesn't exist. Don't, don't,
don't acknowledge my favorite.
And if people are like,
well then what should we do?
My favorite thing ever that that apparent
did is literally walk their kid up to
me and say, hello sir, this is my son.
He's not quite sure why you're smaller,
but I wanted to come and say hi to you.
So he, so he knows that you're, that
you're just another human being.
And then I went, thank you.
Thank you for doing that.
Cause then I got to talk to the kid and
people think, oh, was the kid, the kid,
the kid,
he was like five or six.
I could've gone with a joke and
be like 27, you know, but like,
like people freak out about their
kids because they think like,
they think they have to make up these
magical stories for their children. Like,
oh, well, you know, um, he,
the tooth fairy came and when the
tooth fairy shrinks down teeth,
they got some dust on that guy.
And then he like,
he shot like they think that it's like,
no,
I literally just tell kids when they
go, why you little? I go, all right.
You see how that person has blonde Terry?
So that person has black hair. He goes,
that person has no hair. Yeah,
some people are really tall,
some people are really short.
That's all. And they go, okay,
that's what you told that like five
or six year olds and they go, okay.
And that's all you need to tell
kids is like essentially the truth.
And they're like, oh yeah,
yeah. All right. And then
cause that's what they want.
They want the truth. They want to learn,
they want you to get some fancy story.
So yeah, the, the, the, the white
parents are always more like, ah,
he ate gluten. You know,
like they like freak out.
Uh,
Mexicans and Latinos in general say shit
but in Spanish because then they see
that I'm obviously a gringo and a
so they say shit, but it's like I,
I know all the words for dwarf.
So it's like [inaudible]
like I know all that shit.
So when I hear those little keywords
that's go Kaitlin, you know?
Um,
and then my favorites are black kids
cause they just don't give a fuck.
They don't care. They
don't care. I'm literally,
I'm literally kid walk up to me and be
like, what the Hell is wrong with you?
It was the greatest thing and
I'm just like, yes. Awesome.
Good for you. Dad's right behind them.
Yeah. What the Hell is wrong with you?
I got questions like,
why you short as hell man.
Genetics,
Jesus Christ genetics.
I bought crack from that motherfucker
laying up like tap and like look at him.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. I don't like that.
Like a wheel house. Great. Yeah.
That's your wheelhouse. Yeah.
Say something to say that I have an answer
for everything when it comes to that.
Oh, that's why it's always,
that's not what I said,
but yeah, like that's when someone like
does like a real basic heckle. Right.
I just kind of look at him like you
really think I've never heard that before.
What's the thing you hear the most?
Oh so like a Leprechaun joke or something.
And this is in life or on stage?
Both. And on stage. Oh yeah.
I've gotten like where's your buttock?
Gold
from the stage. And I go, it's a,
it's at your mom's house after I paid or
when I fucked her, cause she's a whore.
And then like everyone goes nuts.
It's like it's my first time. Yeah.
You'd be like, Oh yeah, I'm stumped
with the, with the fucking Leprechaun.
Haeckel I got nothing.
And you just,
we've talked about you
on this show before.
I've heard people have tweeted me and
said that you guys say very nice things
about me. So thank you.
Destroy it. There is no,
I know, cause I did a casino with you
like many, many years ago. Very bad knob.
Oh yeah. It was fucking terrible. But
yeah, I mean, I ate a bag of dicks.
Jerry did. Okay. And then
you went up and I was like,
there's no way this guy's
going to salvage this.
You fucking destroyed
the specials. And that told this
story. This was salmon. Well, we were,
when we did a casino, yeah.
Was Colusa casino or then,
yeah, I'll be like view me,
I think Jay Larson. No. Who
was it Larson or was it,
what's his name was Larson. Larson was
there. You're right, it was Larson. Yeah.
And the guy was like, Hey Brad, what do
you want these guys to do? I was like,
excuse me, we're booked on the show.
And he was like, what? He's like,
yeah, Brad's been here before.
I'm like, yeah, I know, but
like Brad didn't bring us,
like we got booked to do the show.
And he was like,
so you'll do 10 and you'll do 10 and brown
will take care of the rest were like,
hold on a second man.
Lately. Dismissive of us.
Like I've Jay. And he was like, he's the
way, I didn't tell that guy to do that.
I 100% okay.
I just want that to be clear.
One of the nicest people and well that's
why everybody is happy for your success
because when you're a dick and
your success, everyone's like,
you can't wait till he
fucking falling on space,
but everybody is thrilled for your
success because you're a good guy.
Oh thanks man. Yeah, I'll watch.
That was a great show cause like you
look back at that show, you're like, oh,
those are all like, yeah,
back at that time we weren't.
But in terms of like they
talk about like the uh,
draft class, the quarterback class of
1983 with like Jim Kelly, John Elway,
like it was a great show. Like it's that
it's that kind of thing. We were like, oh,
all these guys like went on to do like
fucking amazing things before I forget.
I did the degenerates together. Yes,
we did. Yeah. Coming out in the fall,
and I don't know if they're
calling it the degenerates or not,
but something like that.
It's me, you, it's a
big Jay Oakerson a young Nigga centers
and lies of trainer was the trigger.
Trager sorry. Yeah, Dude. This
guy though, this guy was like,
he was constantly, he was like, Brad,
you want to do you want him to go for it?
And I was like, dude, what the fuck?
He's like, well, you guys know,
like you're not closing this year.
And we're like, okay, fine. Yeah,
but you don't have to keep reminding us
that. He's like, yeah, this is Brad show.
Ah, fucker. You're going to
pass the ball to Coby, right?
Like you're going to do Douche
douchebags and your audience. I mean,
they have to just be eating it after,
you know what I mean?
Like the guy that yelled
at the Leprechaun, oh dude,
no one turns that person.
He goes, great. Hackle fucking
great job. I mean, really?
Yeah. You really made the show. But
like, that never happens. Sorry,
I interrupted you because I'm
curious to hear about your life too.
So what other things do people say
to you that's like so lame? And
I mean, like the Leprechaun
things pretty constant. Uh, now,
uh,
now that I'm married there we,
we get questions a lot like strange will
just walk up to me and my wife because
my wife's not a dwarf.
Like they've got questions like,
like what?
Like everyone wants to know how we
met. Like everyone's just like, ah,
how, how'd that happen?
Yeah, that's fucking rude.
Cause like, I know what they're
thinking and they're like, all right,
someone ordered someone. You'd
be like, ah, this is a weird,
yeah. And then then I have
to tell them and that,
that freaks them out even
more because, uh, how did you,
I don't know what he meant. We uh, I
met my wife, this is a 100% true story.
I was doing a radio gig in San Francisco.
Um,
I didn't know anyone there.
I was living in San Francisco and you
were living there. I was living there,
there very briefly.
I got this rate.
I did like four years in a row
where I did 48 weeks on the road.
I was burned out. Someone said like, Hey,
there's this radio gig in San Francisco.
Do you want to be a morning show guy?
He was like, yeah, what's the money
get good. Awesome. I'll take it.
So I did it just to get off the road.
So to start with this show,
I knew no one in San Francisco,
so we played this game on the show
called Tinder or Grindr where I,
where I would flip a coin and
based on what it would land on,
I would go on either a
Tinder date or grinder date.
This is how you hope it gets better.
So then I did it,
did land on a grinder date one time
and I did go on one Grindr date with a
lovely, a redhead, uh, that we,
that he insisted that we just called them
ginger bear. I never got his real name.
Uh, and he was amazing. He was the best,
uh, so caught up or know of course, uh,
up up dumb. No, it was the weirdest
thing cause like we told them like, hey,
you know, Brad's not gay. I'm not gay.
Like when that's not gonna happen.
This is just the way I can meet people
and meet friends and stuff like that.
And he's like, yeah, that's
fine. And he paid for everything.
And like at the end of the night,
I'm like,
I should probably just jerk this guy off,
like I should do something.
Aw,
yeah. So, um, then a listener
called in and said, okay,
you guys do Tinder,
Grindr,
but have you ever heard of this other
APP called Thrinder? And we're like,
what the hell is then Thrinder and they
said, oh, it's Tinder for threesomes.
And I'm like, well obviously I should
get on that watch. That's an APP.
I should be on it again,
a Tinder,
it's not called Tinder anymore or it's
not called Thrinder anymore cause Tinder
sued them. So now it's called
field f e l d a. So yeah,
that's what the name of the
APP is. And uh, so I go, yeah,
I'll go on this Thrinder APP.
That sounds great. And uh,
I matched just for
threesomes. Yeah. And well,
you can go on and match with two singles.
You can go on as a couple
match with a single. Oh,
I got go on as a single match
with a couple or you can
match with another single
and be like, okay, so we gel. So
now let's go find the third. Uh,
so I go on with the single like
let's just baby steps. Let's try it.
Deal for a bit. This is for a radio bit
or no? Well yeah, this is for a radio bit,
but at the same time, my head, I'm like,
I want to get a fucking threesome. Okay.
So yeah. Uh, that respect.
So I went on the APP and uh,
I matched with a single woman and we were,
and we were like, all right, cool. Let's
meet and make sure we're not psychos.
And we met and we weren't Psychos,
but we work on that APP strictly just
for like, let's just hook up. It's a,
it's a thing. Yeah. And then at the end
of the first day, we're like, we, we,
we can't hook up cause this,
there was like something here.
There was a connection.
Yeah. And that's my wife.
Two years after that, two
years after that, I proposed
to her. Wow. I'm on. Yeah.
Marijuana threesome out.
You dirty fucking filthy hookers.
Horse Lot sex ended up,
yeah,
a couple of slots.
And you ended up finding love.
How insane is that when sleds find love?
Yeah.
That's unbelievable.
It's so you met,
do you tell black people
this whole story when was
in front of their children? Let me
tell you about the birds and the bees.
Sometimes the birds and the
bees want to add a caterpillar.
Yeah,
that's how we met.
It's an insane story and
a, that's remarkable. Yeah.
So when people say like, Brad, why
are you like, why'd you settle down?
It's just like, cause I found a hot
Chinese woman that likes three ways.
What was I waiting for?
Like what's where you're like,
oh I'm going to hold off for something
better. She met her in San Francisco then.
Yeah, Marin, San Francisco.
I lasted about not like four
months on the radio show.
How did you get out of the, don't
you have contract? I paid it off.
You paid off your contract. I
was that miserable. You hit it.
What was the worst part? Is it the
morning? Not even the mornings.
The worst part is that when
you're done with the show,
you sit down and meeting after the show
and some guy who has worked his way up
to be program director tells
you how to be funny. Oh,
that's the thing where he's like,
here's what you need to be doing.
That's the part where I was literally
like, I know I can't do this.
I can't have someone who's
never been funny in their
lives. Help me. Tell me how,
tell me how to be funny because of that.
Because at that time I was 12
years in and then he'd stand up.
Do you have an agent goes
make the call for you? Like
he's got to go. Yeah, I mean,
I, I told the agent, I was
like, I'm out. And they're like,
it's going to cost to you. I'm
like, don't care. Don't care.
Give me back on the road giving back. Just
write a check to them. They're gone. Go.
And uh, how many days a week were you
doing it? Five. Yeah. So, and it was,
it was the morning show.
It was 6:00 AM to 10:00 AM funded it
all from 6:00 AM to 10:00 AM was great
until you did it. Have Fun doing on the
show was fantastic. That was a lot of fun.
A lot of fun bits.
The people that were on the show were uh,
were really talented and
that part was amazing. Uh,
it's just every other part that sucked
like afterward and then finally getting
out of all the meetings and show prep at
like three o'clock and now you're like,
well it's three o'clock.
I have about two hours to do something
and then I have to go to bed.
That's how long you have to be there.
W I mean cause after the show then you
go to a meeting and you run down the bits
that work, especially as a new show.
You, you, you went on the bits that work,
the bits that didn't, and then
you plan the show tomorrow and how
do you know it's a radio show?
There's no audience that you
can actually hear the laughter.
How do you know what worked and
what did not work? Director is God.
And just, and that's why I was like, no,
I can't, I can't do it. He
goes, you need a live audience.
They'll tell you what's funny.
Yeah.
And we had great reaction
on like the phone lines.
People would be calling up and be like,
this is, this is amazing. This is great.
We haven't heard anything
like this before. And then
like, yeah, that didn't work.
Uh, that's not, that's not what you do in
radio. It's like, that's a dying medium.
So maybe let's not do what you fucking do.
You fuck
you. Fuck you. Fuck you twice. Okay.
I would love to see two Hungarian
people who know Hungarian still fighting
English. Oh man, that's the best part.
Your mother queen of Laura's got
fucked her ass hole. You'll fuck ass.
She prepared me for meeting her mom.
Like my mom's wild and I was like,
my mom's crazy now. My mom's like
real pretty nuts. I was like,
sure.
And it was like for like a month.
And then we went to lunch and she
was like, hello? She goes, hi,
nice to meet you.
And she turns to Christina and she goes,
I was at a blooming dads
in this fucking cunt.
I couldn't. I said, fuck you
bitch. You take it back now.
And I was like at a restaurant.
I was like, oh my God,
I was so happy though.
I was laughing so hard.
Can I tell you that you're the first
man I ever brought home that laughed at
that shit and that's why we're able
to be married. You Know Casey Anthony
killed her daughter as she gave
you a blow job, right? That's true.
That is the other side of
this car. Oh Man. Yeah.
Cause you see that and you go, oh great,
there's another broken toy like me there.
You fantastic. Not so much
fun. It was fine. Christine,
we've got an email that says,
did Tina take a monster shit,
she looks lighter to Mac.
Did you
ask me one of my favorite jokes that
you ever did? Where you talking about,
I didn't know I was pregnant
womb to take a shit,
but it wasn't as shit to it.
Tom was a baby
that show,
that show was another show that should
be on the shot and four channel,
100% and the other show.
What's the other one? Dude,
we watched it.
We got the TLC APP.
You can watch a show on the road.
Basically the network you're describing,
it's like fucking, you know, uh,
it's addiction boarding,
right? 600 pounds,
600 pounds. And I'm black. Like it'll
be combinations of things. Holidays.
I'm Mormon and 600 pounds getting those
hands and I want to marry three dwarves.
It's all these things. So
anyways, we're scrolling through.
We watched lost in transition,
which is about people transitioning
like in the middle of their marriage.
Like you guys are too old and then you
go, I'm a woman. Wow. I was like, what?
So it's those. Okay. And these
were scrolling through and we see,
I still didn't know I was pregnant.
So open that up.
This is about people who had burr gave
birth, women who gave birth, right.
Didn't know they were pregnant.
Yeah.
And then a second time gave birth and
didn't know they were pregnant again.
Another big shit. And I was
like, fuck it. Not Again,
not a bad shit again. It was all
fog. That's a big shit. Whoa, whoa.
What is that?
That show is basically the plot
of the hangover too, right? Yeah.
They're like, this can't happen twice.
It's weekend at Bernie's too. Of course.
It's every horrible seek or they're like
the unbelievable situation that made
the first one amazing. Even
now it happened again to
not know you're pregnant.
You have to be so mentally
ill or so in denial,
like the brain can actually block out a
lot of stuff when you're trying to not
listen. Christina, why while you
tried a woman's playing this shit,
let the men talk about how
you know you're pregnant.
Please Polish Jesus. I
mean, I knew nothing about,
I know this fucking
dumb, broad ideas, words,
words like this. Can you
imagine not knowing? I mean,
you saw me at the very end.
I couldn't even, I could barely walk.
Like days before you give birth,
you were ready to hop in Vegas at the
special. That was eight months pregnant.
He was shy. Eight months. Yeah. And you
were wearing this horror cowgirl outfit.
Oh girl. How dare you
paint that. Oh, sorry.
I thought you meant my dress
and I actually wore, I was
like, oh no, no, no, no, no.
Not that spectacular. And that outfit.
Thank you. They put me in a, yeah,
it's bad for the Bachelorette party.
Yeah. You're a bachelor party.
So you were in like a Bret Michaels
sparkly pink cowboy hat. Great.
We were talking about, by the
way, sorry, the, um, you know,
people who you see in public on
speaker phone and they're like, Hey,
no, I'm a, I'm going to walk in now, but
what's that? And then you're like, dude,
you're on speaker phone. Yeah. And
they'll have a full conversation. Yeah.
And just how, you know, we should just
have bullet to the back of the head.
Oh yeah. All of them. The
assembly. I don't like that
you're on board. No, I don't.
Finally, it's weird because there,
there's certain things when,
here's how, you know, a movie villain
is a good villain when it's wrong,
what they're doing. But in your
head you go, I totally get it right.
I totally understand it.
It's a great point.
So like when thanatos wants to
kill half the universe and say,
dude,
we're
fucked up,
we,
there's too many people and not all of
them are good and we just have to wipe
that to kill half the people
have a horse that's wrong. Right.
But damn it that I kind of want that
to happen. As you start with India,
where does it fit? I'm just
saying what did he do? It, it, it,
it's random. It's completely
random. There's, there's that,
there's actually an APP and it's,
it's stupid,
but you just type your
name in and then you hit
enter and then it says you were spared
by Thanos or you were killed by that. Oh,
I was spared just saying it. Ah,
so yeah, I, I'd still be here,
but us, he's taking no prisoners though.
It could be anybody. Yeah. Anybody. Wow.
So yeah, and like, so yeah,
that's obviously something
that should not happen.
You should fight to make sure that
doesn't happen. But at the same time,
if you're one of the ones
that stage, you're like, wow,
there's a lot less traffic.
Nice. This is nice. I saw this. This
is my own recording. Okay. Okay.
In Starbucks where this guy
was eating his breakfast. Yeah,
the coffee and we're all just trying
to get our coffee. Enjoy your morning.
This motherfucker's on hold.
Yeah, with Bank of America. Okay.
That's it on speaker phone.
Puts the phone on speakerphone on the,
just on the [inaudible]
Taylor. It's him in the
red shirt there. Okay.
So we all have to listen to his cold.
I don't want to hear that shit. Right.
Just a total fucking psycho.
As we talked about this,
those people exist or they watch their
videos at full volume or listen to their
music. Full volumes. Oh,
we, oh, we went to, uh,
my wife and I went to a movie
and three rows ahead of us.
There was a guy like on an iPad and
like no headphones and like listening to
videos while a movie's going on while
the movie's On, while the movie's on,
not during the previews,
just movies on and he bought out
the iPad like no one said anything.
No. My, my wife threw a quarter
at them and gay older. Nailed it.
That's fucking really risky, right?
Yeah. But at the same time, what he do,
he just got up and like turned around and
then sat back down and close the IPAD.
It was, it was like a full fucking
psycho. I looked at my wife like,
I've never loved you more
than this moment. Right.
Told me a story about a guy who was at
a movie theater near him and put his,
he put his feet up on the chair. Yeah.
Start talking on the phone. Nope.
My Dad got a local sheriff
walking around and was like,
there a guy in there making a problem.
I love you said that the sheriff
went in there and fucking knock.
The guys feed off. The guy's like, get the
fuck Outta here. Ah, I love that so much.
It sounds like some Florida shit.
Right.
I was expecting that to go horribly wrong.
Like the Sheriff looks at
your dad and goes like, hey,
you're crazy. You're going,
oh no, no, that's, that's
awesome. See like, yeah.
That's when I just think, and I lit. I
literally think that we should develop a
birth control in a spray where when you
see that you should just be like,
eh, that camera and just take that.
Not Permanent.
It's like,
it's like a two week birth control that
where it's just like, all right, you know,
permanent,
white well I think might give them an
opportunity Q test administered well
listen,
well that takes away the Forrest Gump.
Like this is what this guy said.
He Goes, my name is Collin. Yeah,
I was listening to the big
you guys recently had about
people talking on phones
and video calls on speaker
without earphones in public.
I work at regional trauma hospital and
the other day I was working on triage
patients in the Er lobby and there was
a middle aged woman who kept repeatedly
using the voice commands on her phone
to call people and then putting the call
on speakerphone and
loudly talking to them.
I have patients coming from motor
vehicle accidents, having heart attacks,
strokes,
all matter of life threatening problems.
And she's loudly screaming into her
phone about what kind of spaghetti she's
going to have that night. So I can't
even hear the person in front of me.
These are the worst kinds of people.
Oh, congratulations on the baby.
I'm sorry Tina.
But Tommy will always be the water champ.
I'm all finished them all done in time
for Moose suit by Hitler's Collin from
Fort Pierce. Oh, that's
wow. Road for me. That is a,
that's insane. Like, yeah, if
that's the point, like, Hey,
this guy is like, oh, I have
vitals and they're dropping.
And then you've got to hear like fucking
Marinara sauce. What's going on, man?
You imagine if you're like of like they're
coming to you and like saying like,
Hey, I'm your husband. Um, do
we pull the plug? Like he's not,
and all you hear
in the background and add some Oregano
you, but you're just like, kill him.
Just fucking killer. Fucking
fucking kill him. Not the past,
not the grade at the slice. And they're
like, the husband wake up. You're like,
kill me. Kill me. I don't live in
that world. I want to live here.
If I like to batch your Starbucks example,
if someone has a piece,
if someone calls me and I'm going to
Starbucks, I'll leave the Starbucks,
leave the Starbucks to take to take that
phone call or like just go to my corner
or whatever.
And like I'm so like hypersensitive
to like how my shit could ruin someone
else's name. These people don't
like how you not, they're just not,
they're just not aware of it.
They're totally unaware and
football season is approaching.
We're wondering DTE talk,
we taught CTE talk.
When does a lot of the preseason started?
Yeah.
So precision is already
gone for four weeks. Um,
I just finished the man cave and
my house. I'm psyched. Ready?
We are talking about, you know, there's
a lot of, you know what I'm saying is,
and we always keep track of who says,
you know what I'm saying a lot. Oh Man.
And uh,
here we have Tom Brady in a, you know,
interview doing a lot. Oh No. Cool. Okay.
Okay.
She sounds just walked
in. Hi Cutie. Over there.
How has being with her enhanced your life?
Oh Man. Every possible way.
It really has. She's just,
um, I couldn't imagine a better partner
for me in my life, what I've gone through.
Okay,
so you both grew up with siblings.
She had five sisters and I had three
sisters, so it's a lot of women,
you know, and it's, you know, she
comes from a different country,
you know,
Dan's to move to New York
when she was 17 and you know,
we met each other under trying
circumstances, you know,
like every company work,
you know,
we love each other,
we support each other and we also live
in our life and we're trying to find ways
to, you know, thing and she's
working on, I'm working,
there's a lot of things happen on,
but how do we always reconnect with
one another? It's another one in there,
but I believe, you know, like I
couldn't find a better woman to,
to love me and support me the
way she does it all cut together.
Good motherfucker right there. You know
what I'm saying? Here's the, uh, here's,
I'm mad. I'm mad about the setup question.
I know we're over. Just goes, oh,
has she enhanced your life?
Like high blood,
everything.
Here's the super care.
It's a lot of women.
No, you know, you know, you know, you
know, like, you know, read, you know,
like you know it's a lot of your nose.
One answer. Yeah, that's
solid. I just hate those.
Like when you're giving
an interview and they,
those softball questions of like worst.
So is your wife the best woman in
the world or in the known universe?
We get a lot of, um, is it
just jokes all day with,
yes.
When the baby's shitting and on
our faces and we can't control it.
She's, you guys run a lot of bits by each
other and like, yeah, all day. Every day.
As I was pushing our second
child out and our first,
we had a nurse like this who was like
the jokester of the, the nurse Ward.
She came out of nowhere and
she came over and were like,
and at one point I want to be like,
can someone get fucking shaky out of here?
Because there's time to Joe and Tom and I,
we're not joking.
No pushing out our child.
Like it's not a time do not at all.
The worst. The worst thing as a comedian
is when you like, cause we have uh,
the post office by my house has,
I went there to mail a package
and then they went, hey,
do I know you from somewhere?
And they go like,
ah, you're a comedian, you're a
comedian, you're a funny guy. Like Hey,
I'm a comedian. Okay. Yeah. And
then they go rich or go over here.
He's the funny guy in our office.
You guys are going to love,
you guys can get along great. And
I'm like, this is not a play date.
You don't set us up.
And like that's the worst when cause
then it's the worst for the other guy.
I feel bad for the other guy cause he's
like probably the funny guy around the
office and it's probably
good to be like and yeah.
And then I'm the professional funny guy
and now he's under pressured like Ah
Shit.
I gotta be funny right now.
Like we're professional comedians and
we don't like it when someone says be
funny right now. That's very nice of you
to even think like that. Yeah. Mm hmm.
Yeah, it's like that. That's got to
suck for that dude. Do you have a,
can you weigh in on what you think
this means? This is just an image.
What is gt? Rtd. All right. Well,
first of all, that is Steven Seagal.
Yeah. Uh, with a tiny face and a fat head,
which is pretty much how it looks now.
And that is pretty much, that's pretty
much this. Just like pretending,
pretending he's not in it. It doesn't
have anything to do with Stephen. Yeah.
It doesn't have anything
to do with upper right.
And what do you think that means?
Yes.
See it. Just go for it. This is,
this is a word that I don't,
I don't think I'm allowed to say,
but I think it's trying
to get me to say it. No.
Like what's that a word for gay people?
That's kind of derogatory.
Hmm. I don't see that at all.
Yeah, that's what you think.
This is the top part. What
about the bottom part? Uh,
so it's like,
get rid of the words I've,
oh yeah.
Does that,
does that reveal a lot of hatred in my
person that I see? No, that's interesting.
It's like a Rorschach test for it is
because different people have different
reactions. What, what, what
are the reactions have you
gotten? Forget that. Tick.
I mean, I know first good
tongue replaces that dick first.
Good tug replaces that. Yeah.
Okay. That was it. And then we had,
that's a tea RTD was Ri. I'm an
idiot. Yeah, no, no, that's okay.
Oh, I see what? Yes, I
could see that too. Okay.
So there's no answer is literally just
for great times. Rubbed that Dick.
That was one um,
fat guy too.
He was making these updated to die.
Um,
let's see. We're good time, right?
To Dean Faculty to ride the
Dick decays and rape the death.
And that's just the words to live by
fucking gays and then raped the Daphnis.
It's pretty intense. Hold on, I just got
done. Fucking the gaze. What do I do now?
Okay. The death is Riley.
My interpretation of
gaze then raped to death.
There is no right or wrong.
There's no right or wrong.
You see and you said get rid of gays.
Yeah.
Yeah. That's what I saw.
And this guy's legit.
That might be [inaudible] message. I can
say that this was just submitted to us.
Sure.
So is that something that,
is that like the new Obama hope
poster and that seems like it has
cause isn't he the ambassador to
Russia? No, he's not the bathroom.
No he is not.
He is a Russian citizen now
and the Kremlin has appointed
him special envoy like
he is.
It's an unpaid position for to enhance
humanitarian relations between the US and
Russia, that rights. But it is hilarious.
It's guess relationship to Taco.
It does super fan and his hair's so dark.
It's amazing.
Yeah. He's, he's one of those guys
where I'm sure he uses like shoe Polish,
unlike black, this woman had,
we put jet, this woman has been played
on our show before. This lady here,
it gives one a bag on the go as
well. Grab. You ain't never had that.
Yeah. We played her before then
leading into a car. You remember?
You remember that?
I'll make you asshole whistle
dance all night. Wait.
But she, she wasn't sucking
a dick through wire fence.
She was saying she was leaning
into a car. Yeah, that's her. Yeah,
that's her. That's her. Could
someone put a beat to that?
Yes, they can. As a matter of fact.
Cause someone do that. Put it out there.
Is there, is there like a remix to that?
Cause she was Ryman. Yeah, it's coming.
You could drop a sick beat. Yeah. It just
said the word sick beat. I'm over 30,
uh,
and make that one of those like viral
remixes or she's known to wrap. She's,
she's dropped this Ryan.
Before that she was leaning into a car.
So we've seen this woman do this.
Ryan, she's a second socket.
Tick off the gristle make you a whistle.
It's good.
Look,
it's her
chunk on the gag on the couch.
No brainer that this woman has teeth.
The other woman,
I felt like the rhythm of it.
How you doing? How you
most, she's got my tits.
Look the ass lick the balls with that the
way down my throat choke on a gig on a
but for high 60.
How tight this one
that's on the end there. How many
shorter street? It's two one.
She does mention the asshole here too
similar when I'm licking that ass doesn't
know. Awesome. That's uh, that's
what they call a go getter.
Sure. Good for her. Is that definitely
not her? Maybe this woman has teeth.
The other woman didn't have teeth
and this
all night long. Like you wish when
they both have a rhythm to this.
Yeah, I see a name. Thank [inaudible].
Good. It's a good advertisement.
Yeah. Yeah. It pretty much puts it all
out there and moving along here. Okay.
Another time lifting thing. We can
now add on something like that. Um,
Brad, thanks for coming by.
Oh, what's your podcast?
My podcast is the about
last night podcast. Uh,
our guest this week is Steevo, but
yeah, if you got them right. Yeah.
With the fantastic Adam Ray.
Uh, we've had Sandra Bullock on,
we've had Melissa McCarthy on,
we've had a bill or Jim Jefferies.
We have not had Thompson,
Sarah and Christina p and
that I have been on the show.
You have? Yes. When were
you on our show? Oh Wow.
That must have been like in our first year
or something. I had been on your show.
Oh, we're, were you in our show
back to the John Lovitz club? No,
I went to someone's apartment. All
right. That was Adam's. Fuck. Really?
I'm Brad's two for two.
Literally not a memorable episode.
We've had Thompson girl apparently.
Go back and find that episode.
Go back and find, I'm going to go
back and find that episode. No,
I had a good time with you guys. Um, uh,
I did too. We should have Adam on too.
He's fantastic.
He remembers Stevie is the
better half. No, you can
listen to about last night. Uh,
make sure you are,
he has two other specials already
or I have fun size and daddy issues,
which are either on the showtime
anytime app or a now on Amazon prime.
Amazon prime is an easy way to watch
it for free. If you have Amazon prime.
There you go.
Then a degenerates coming or whatever it
was going to be called on Netflix soon
and you can see Brad
burping through his emotion.
It's special. Special. Thank you.
We got a 2001.
Uh, you know what I'm saying?
Um, you know what I'm saying?
And you can also see Brad is
the site of Rob williams.com.
[inaudible] dot com for all,
all my tour dates and information and the
dates coming up. Anything coming up. Uh,
this, when does this come out?
Just comes out tomorrow. All right.
It will be a this weekend. I am at
Cap City Comedy Club in Austin, Texas.
Then I'm at the Ontario
Improv the following weekend.
W I'm booked through 29 13.
You guys have to go and see bradies very,
very funny and checking.
I've show you will laugh
a lot. Um, anyways,
this is please come on our podcast.
Oh yeah, I'd love to, yeah.
One of these days for stroke gang by
bones. Mckenzie going to take us out.
Thank you again for coming, Brad.
Thank you guys. See you guys next week.
Correct.
J Smith
was a smile
or a smooth harder. My Dick
get this. Unbelievable.
If you want to see it, if you
don't, that's okay too. I won't,
I'm pregnant. So biggest dick was
or drill,
drill,
drill.